bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement ou j'accueille
michael launay big mat synonyme au doux
nom de victor sur youtube
bonjour michael genre ça va ça va bien
très très bien donc michael tien
notamment sa chaîne youtube
michael launay fait des vidéos de maths
et puis là aussi plusieurs livres et
puis dans le parc odeur est ce que tu
peux commencer par présenter un peu ton
parcours scolaire et professionnel
bah alors scolaire j'ai fait des études
de maths comme on peut s'en douter
j'ai jusqu'au jusqu'au bac s j'ai suivi
un parcours assez classique est quand
même en au lycée j'ai commencé à faire
un peu de vulgarisation même temps que
que mes études parce que j'avais un prof
de maths qui nous faisait des tours de
magie mathématiques qui a commencé à me
faire baigner un peu dans ce milieu là
donc il m'a entraîné dans des
associations qui faisaient des salons de
jeux mathématiques les choses comme ça
et puis après j'ai un peu suivi
les deux voies de la vulgarisation et
mes études de maths un peu en parallèle
et donc j'ai fait une classe
préparatoire mps im pei à bordeaux au
lycée michel montaigne
suite à quoi je fais entrer à l'école
normale supérieure de paris et j'ai
terminé avec une thèse en probabilité à
marseille il y aurait quatre ans qui
s'est terminée en 2012 et donc est donc
à la fin de cette thèse je me suis posé
la question est ce que je fais de la
recherche est ce que je continue dans la
recherche ou est ce que je me laisse
tenter par par la vulgarisation par la
médiation scientifique qui me tentait
bien aussi et ben voilà j'avais le choix
que j'ai fait je suis parti dans la
médiation et voilà je le fais ça depuis
septembre non supérieur et du coup de
tête faire de la magie c'est la magie
des tours purement mathématiques ou de
faits aussi d'amener ces sas est un
détour des tours de magie avec des trucs
mathématiques donc les tours de cartes
où il fallait compter enfin il est d'une
certaine manière il faudrait comprendre
une logique sur les mélanges de cartes
sur la façon de mélanger qui faisaient
que quand on répétait un mélange un
certain nombre de fois telle carte
revenir à la mets au même emplacement
ou alors des tours avec des tours un peu
de topologie par exemple comment avec
une ficelle on a l'impression qu'une
ficelle est prise autour d'un cloud
quelque chose comme ça puis ça s'envole
de façon magique il ya des noeuds qui se
défendent des choses comme ça donc voilà
le genre de tournage et où des détours
juste avec des nombres ont fait ont
demandé un spectateur de penser un
nombre et puis on lui fait faire des
opérations puis à la fin on trouve
magiquement sans ombre et quand on
connaît un peu l'algèbre comprend un peu
comment ça fonctionne
mais quand on ne sait pas forcément
comment ça marche bien ça peut paraître
totalement étonnant que de retrouver le
nombre de départs sans avoir les
informations à priori nécessaire et
utile
ton prof de lycée vous montrer ses tours
où il fut volé faisait tournoyer en fait
il était alors ce n'était pas vraiment
mon prof de maths traditionnel pas celui
qui me faisait les cours de maths mais
il animait à un club de jeu mathématique
entre midi et deux tous les lundis et
donc forcément j'étais toujours fourré
dans ce club de jeux mathématiques et
voilà il nous posait des énigmes et nous
et nous et nous entraîner pour
participer à des concours comme concours
kangourou des championnats de jeux
mathématiques et oui lui son grand dada
donc il s'appelle dominique soder ce
prof pour citer son nom est d'ailleurs
il a écrit les livres de magie
mathématique si jamais ça vous intéresse
et donc se voir et ce tous les lundis on
allait au club de jeu m'a t on parlait
régulièrement il y avait des tours de
magie mathématique n'est sûr car testait
des fois il rit on inventait des détours
dont il est resté un peu sur nous à
l'aller puis après la semaine d'après il
avait amélioré deux fois nous mêmes en
prenaient au jeu et je me suis amusé à
en créer quelques uns aussi et et voilà
donc c'était assez amusant mais
d'ailleurs il y en a quelques-uns que
j'ai posté sur sur la chaîne je crois
que des tours de magie de tours de magie
mathématiques à faire pour impressionner
guy avec les maths c'est comme ça que tu
étais intéressé aux matous août avait
déjà un intérêt marqué je n'avais jamais
déjà bien les matchs en fait avant le
lycée j'aimais vraiment les sciences en
général
j'étais de plus par an chez astronomie
en fait avant le lycée jeu j'étais le
petit passionner pour les étoilés pour
aurait l'astrophysique donc quand dans
les fiches qu'on nous demandait de
remplir au début d'année quand on me
demandait quel métier je veux tu faire
jusqu'à la seconde à peu près je marque
et astrophysicien et des cris et puis
après je suis parti de plus en plus dans
les mathématiques alors oui
effectivement c'est un peu avec ce club
de jeu matt que j'ai découvert surtout
ce qu'étaient les mathématiques parce
que jusqu'au lycée je me rendais pas du
tout content que c'était que c'était
aussi vaste je pensais naïvement que que
au bac on aurait terminé les maths et
qu'après il y avait plus qu'à faire des
applications
et puis je me suis rendu compte qu'en
fait non mais en fait c'était c'était un
peu plus vaste que ça et que qu'il avait
il y avait vraiment de quoi explorer
dans cette discipline
donc oui c'est vraiment dans ces années
là dans ces trois années de lycée où je
me suis dit ouais les maths ça
m'intéresse bien et ça vaut le coup
d'être étudiée pour soi je suis parti
quand j'étais au collège j'avais un truc
de ces des parcours d'orientation avec
des conseils de carrière que je risque
un truc sur ordinateur on entre et nos
préférences et que moi j c j'aime les
maths et à chaque fois ça me sortez soit
expert comptable soit astrophysiciens ah
oui c'est pas là c'est pas la même chose
il y aurait dit des deux mathématiciens
comme métier c'est derrick à s'éloigner
ouais je n'étais pas dans leur fiche
n'est pas dans leurs cases et du coup
est ce que tu es des modes que tu
préfères forte plus tôt analyse oui j'ai
eu ça dépend ça dépend des jours
je crois que justement une des choses
que j'aime dans fait de faire de la
vulgarisation aujourd'hui c'est le fait
de ne pas être obligé de me spécialiser
de pouvoir toucher un peu à tout après
ce que je peux dire c'est qu'il ya des
matches dans lesquels je suis meilleur
que d'autres
j'ai fait une thèse en probable parce
que les probables je sais pas mon
cerveau tourne bien dans le sens des
pros bas et berné c'est justement c'est
quelque chose où où les probas j'ai
toujours je comprenais bien c'était
assez intuitif pour moi et je voyais
bien 500 sans forcément les avoir
apprise sans avoir appris les formules
qu'on apprend au lycée jeu c'était
quelque chose pour lequel j'avais l'état
d'esprit l'analyse c'est plus difficile
c'est à dire que c'est quelque chose de
vraiment ça m'a demandé du travail mais
je peux pas dire que j'aime moins ça
parce que c'est une fascination qui est
différente c'est à dire que hier mais il
ya une satisfaction aussi à comprendre
quelque chose sur laquelle on a vraiment
galéré beaucoup dit et qui est
différente mais qui limite est quand
même assez assez poignante quoi est
d'ailleurs à kankan quant à eux nsg
découvert que en réalité d'un point de
vue purement technique les probas était
une sous branches de l'analyse et qu'une
espérance c'était une intégrale fois je
me suis dit tiens c'est ça ça m'a pas
mal des routes est au début et puis et
puis finalement je me suis fait c'est
fou c'est aussi pour ça que c'est
chouette les maths etc et que j'aime
vraiment ça c'est ça crée des liens
inattendus et donc ouais je j'aime
j'aime bien tout les matchs il ya
l'algèbre c'est quelque chose qui me
fascine là pour le coup c'est un peu
entre les deux c'est à dire c'est
quelque chose pour lequel j'ai
l'impression d'avoir plus un esprit
algébrique un esprit de de prob à ne pas
croire d'analystes pardon mais mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya quand même pas mal
de choses sur lesquelles j'ai pu galérer
en adjet c'est pareil j'ai un truc sur
lesquels j'ai vraiment besoin de bosser
encore c'est la topologie
là c'est pareil j'aime bien quand c'est
vulgariser et quand je vois la topologie
vulgariser c'est vraiment fascinant mais
par contre le tout ce qui est technique
derrière la topologie des qu'il faut
faire des calculs
dans des variétés différenciables ou je
ne sais quoi je suis un peu perdu avec
l'abstraction et j'ai du mal à j'ai
encore du mal à faire le lien entre les
visualisations intuitif que que je peux
avoir
et le calcul et sert quand vont à calcul
je n'arrive pas à faire facilement la
transition avec qu'est ce que ça
signifie concrètement en terme d'image
c'est un peu là dedans que je veux
m'aimer du coup le fait que j'ai encore
beaucoup de choses à apprendre ici dans
ce domaine fait aussi que j'ai envie d'y
aller donc pour les auditeurs qui
connaîtraient pas l'analyse l'algèbre de
plus super c de donner un peu
d'intuition de ce que c'est pourquoi
est-ce que ça colle à tour dentition
aider ce que tu es en fait je crois que
que pour dire les choses un peu un peu
de façon très caricatural il ya une
distinction qui se fait assez tôt en
maths c'est celle entre les maths
discrète et les maths continue les maths
discrète c'est quand on compte 0 1 2 3 4
5 6 et puis continue c'est quand on
comprend tout air et qu'on commence à
voir des nombres à virgule et que et que
quand on a un nombre n'y a pas un nombre
suivant c'est quoi le nombre juste après
un bain c'est pas 2 parce qu'il ya 1.5
qu'avant mais il y aussi 1,1 0,1 tout
nombre est noyé dans une mer de nombre
et il n'y a pas deux suivants ni deux
précédents une sorte de continuum et
j'ai un état d'esprit qui aime bien les
choses discrète et un peu plus de mal
dès qu' on part dans le continue c'est
mon cerveau fonctionne moins bien bu
facilement à des intuitions qui sont
fausses et dont il faut lutter contre ça
et je crois que c'est pour ça donc
l'analyse c'est ça va être quand on
étudie à priori des fonctions qui vont
être par exemple des fonctions réelles
ou pour en fonction du temps on a
quelque chose qui évolue et qui a une
valeur une valeur pour chaque pour
chaque instant donné donc c'est
typiquement de l'analyser et ça c'est
des choses sur lesquelles j'ai vu j'ai
eu plus de mal à me forger une intuition
alors que quand on est dans le continuel
l'équivalent en continu d'une fonction
un réel ça va être une suite on invente
la suite de fibonacci où on commence par
un 1 et puis on additionne à chaque fois
les deux termes prétendre un plus un
égale
un plus de 3 de plus royal 5 et ainsi de
suite et donc là ça me semble faire des
raisonnements qui sont beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus franc où on peut découper
le raisonnement en état pendant 10 ans
on a des compartiments on peut dégager
des grandes étapes des choses comme ça
et donc je pense que c'est pour ça que
au lycée j'ai beaucoup aimé les probas
parce que les pro bass est liée à la
combinatoire sert comment est-ce qu'on
dénombre des cantons bien bien de
mélange d'un jeu de cartes il existe
combien de combien de tirage de lotto il
peut ya voir où il faut il faut compter
il faut des nombres et on est
typiquement dans des maths discrète et
puis après forcément les probas
finissent par arriver aussi au mas de
continuer on commence à voir des choses
un peu plus justement qui dérive un peu
plus vers l'analyse mais l'état d'esprit
de base des pros bas d'ailleurs c'est un
peu comme ça que celle apparue qu'en
fermat et pascal échanger entre eux et
que c'était pour étudier des jeux des
jeux des probabilités de gain dans des
jeux des choses comme ça ça reste très
très discret et l algèbre c'est pareil
pourquoi ce que je disais tout à l'heure
je n'avais plus un état d'âme et
d'esprit algébrique que de claude
analyse
en fait ces paris l'algèbre c'est très
vaste donc il ya de l'algèbre discrète
et de l'algèbre continue mais mais mais
quand on apprend au début quand on
commence à apprendre les groupes les
anneaux et des choses comme ça l est
avant d'arriver au corps parce que je
n'arrive encore commencé à faire le lien
peuvent être l'analyse et bien on le
tout ce qui est étude des groupes fini
des choses comme ça je travaillais avec
des nombres qui fonctionne en pendule
donc quand on arrive à présent une
pendule quand on arrive à 12 on reprend
à 1 et donc qui a étudié l'arithmétique
de ce genre de système où on n'a que
douze nombre et qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire qu'est-ce qu'on peut pas faire
pourquoi est-ce que des fois il ya des
divisions on peut faire des divisions
mais des fois on peut pas par exemple
sur une pendule on peut pas faire deux
divisions facilement parce que si on
prend si on veut faire 2 / 4 / 2 vont
pas se dire 4 / 2 ça fait deux
mais en fait comme 4 c'est aussi égale à
16 1 16 / 2 ça fait 8 et donc on sait
pas si 6-4 / 2 ça vaut de 8
donc il ya une sorte d' ambiguïté qui se
crée donc c'est ça c'est des choses qui
me paraissaient que je trouvais vraiment
fascinante et d'essayer de comprendre ça
c'est de trouver la logique là dedans et
pourquoi il ya des choses qui
fonctionnent pareil dans des dents
certains groupes et puis pas dans
d'autres
il ya donc d'envoi la cmu je pense que
c'est un peu ça la frontière entre que
mon cerveau accepte intuitivement est ce
que mon cerveau refuse effectivement
c'est là c'est la frontière entre le
discret il continue continue la samah
challenge est un peu plus et j'avais
pourquoi j'avais prenez ça c'était plus
que l'analyse était plus basse et ses
courbes et tout ça a baissé mais quelque
chose d'assez palpable fage arrivé à
imaginer un peu ses courbes
c'est une dentition et or est erronée et
puis c'est ça que j'aime et en attend
des analystes alors que là j'ai bon
choix et ça a vraiment abstrait mais
j'avais beaucoup de mal à naviguer dans
l'ombre de l'algèbre ouais ouais j'étais
plutôt analystes bah oui mais c'est ça
c'est à dire en fait on croise oui c'est
aussi ça qui est assez intéressant avec
les mac c'est que c'est c'est qu'il ya
plein d'état d'esprit différent c'est à
dire que comme moi quand j'étais au
lycée on me dira mais toi tu es mathieu
août et il ya les matous et les noms
matin dans les matins en elle-même y
aller il ya les analystes les
probabiliste met du coup dans les dents
dans l'analyse toi comment est-ce que tu
visualisait qu'est ce qui faisait que
dans la visualisation
alors je pense qu'il y avait un truc
sont difficiles à visualiser mais
l'exercice que j'avais bien c'est quand
j'arrivais à voir nos visualiser ce qui
se passe essayez de le rendre formel je
pense qu'il ya un gap pas c'est
intéressant on voit que je viens c'est
un jeu que j'aime bien désir bon ben
allal je sens bien que ça va marcher et
c2 et j'ai tout les intuitions police
formés les auditions de certains que je
lui fasse comprendre ça les moments où
il faut jouer avec les epsilon des
choses comme ça non là il me fait passer
sa facture en anglais où il faut il faut
trouver la bonne façon de calibrer
c'est exactement une autre qui tendent
vers moins d'un fair vers 9h08 je suis
d'accord en fait mais en fait c'est ça
c'est à dire que tous tous tout le
plaisir que peuvent avoir les analystes
à étudier ça je le ressens aussi mais
c'est un sentiment qui est venu à la
longue qu un ford nous brusquer un peu
mais mes idées reçues et donc que tu as
fini lui donc dès le début en fait des
dvd de lycée et était intéressé par ea
profité tout a fini par faire ta thèse
improbable petit peu je peux expliquer
un petit peu les grandes lignes de sa
thèse à l'ordre les grandes lignes de ma
thèse c'est alors ça parle de ce qu'on
appelle le hasard renforcée c'est à dire
le typiquement quand on parle quand soro
probabilité on pense par exemple dans le
jeu à un lancer de dés ou on va lancer
un délai puisse avoir une chance sur six
de tomber sur chaque sur chaque face et
puis un des classiques
si on lance deux fois de suite trois
fois de suite sans fois de suite et
baril va pas modifier son comportement
au centième lancée il a toujours une
sans une chance sur 6 2 de tomber sur
chacune des faces le hasard en force et
c'est d'une certaine manière du hasard
qui prend des habitudes c'est à dire que
c'est il faut imaginer un des
intelligents qui aime bien garder ses
petites habitudes et et si on lançait
une première fois et qui tombe sur cinq
est bien là au deuxième lancé il va
avoir tendance à vouloir à aimer
retomber sur cinq est à vouloir leur
faire et plus il va tomber sur cinq
pluie va se renforcer c'est pour ça
qu'on appelle ça le hasard renforcée
c'est plus on a pris une habitude plus
c'est difficile de la quitter et donc
plus il va vouloir le puits va pouvoir
miser c'est comme si à l'intérieur de
lui-même biaiser la façon dont il réagit
c'est physiquement et qu'il est mal
tombée plus sur cinq ou plus sur deux si
j'ai fait plus de 2 avant et ça se
modélise quand on étudie beaucoup avec
des joueurs qu'on appelle des urnes le
pôle yahoo il me faudrait généraliser ou
on prend un grand récipient dans lequel
on met des boules de différentes
couleurs qui différent qui symbolisent
nos différents choix
et puis on tire une boule au hasard on
regarde sa couleur et si par exemple
elle est verte
eh bien on va en remettre on va la
remettre dans le bain
dans notre récipient mais on va remettre
une de plus ce qui fait que le tirage
suivant contrat il y aura plus de boule
verte que l'étape d'avant et donc on
aura plus de chance de tirer à nouveau à
nouveau une boule verte
et donc voilà donc quand on fait ça
qu'est ce qui se passe si on répète un
certain nombre de fois vu des étapes
comme ça on rajoute de plus en plus de
boules nom de bull va tomber à tendre
vers plus l'infini et asymptotiquement
donc quand on quand on fait un nombre
infini de tirage est ce que il va y
avoir une couleur qui va gagner
définitivement il y aura plus que cette
couleur qui gagnera qui sera tiré ou est
ce qu'il ya un équilibre qui va c'est
qui qui va se créer est ce que l on veut
avoir des plusieurs couleurs dominantes
qui peuvent apparaître mais qui vont
rester dans une certaine ça certains
rapports de domination du rhin de les
unes par rapport aux autres
donc voilà c'est le genre de cette genre
de questions qu'on se pose en fonction
des différents paramètres via les
paramètres voilà parce qu'il ya
plusieurs variantes de césium de polliat
selon la façon dont on fait les tirages
au sort et donc voilà donc dans ma thèse
j'ai étudié un processus un peu plus un
peu plus compliqué que ça ou en fait on
a plusieurs urnes qui qui font ce
processus chacune de leur côté et qui de
temps en temps en quelque sorte
s'échangent des boules c'est à dire que
de temps en temps il ya des petits il ya
des petits il ya des boules qui passe
d'un moment à l'autre
il ya une boule qui va être tirée dans
une urne pour une autre urne et et ce
genre de ce genre de choses et pas mal
enfin est utilisée pour modéliser tout
ce qui est processus de prise d'habitude
justement est par exemple en dynamique
des populations si on imagine qu'on a
une population de 2 ne s'est pas de
grenouilles de grenouilles de deux
pièces différentes yves l'espagne à des
grenouilles à taches vertes et des
grenouilles à taches jaunes et qui
appartiennent à la même espèce avant
qu'elles peuvent se reproduire entre
elles mais bien s'il ya plus de
grenouilles attache versilia par deux
tiers de produits à taches vertes dans
une population de grenouilles et bien on
peut imaginer qu'à la génération
suivante c'est bien chaque individu
chaque nouvelle petite bourde ou qui va
naître aura deux chances sur trois
d'avoir des taches vertes et une chance
sur 3 d'avoir des taches jaunes en tout
cas en modèle c'est un modèle simplifié
quoi parce qu'après selon qu'il peut
imaginer qu'il y a
certaines tâches qui ont un avantage
sélectif des choses comme ça donc on
peut ajuster les paramètres mais si on
considère que c'est totalement neutre
ces deux tiers 2/3 de verre et un tir de
jaune mais il ya quand même une part de
hasard si chacune à un tiers deux tiers
chaque chaque nouvelle grenouille qui
n'est arrivé 1/3 2/3 de chances d'être
verte ou jaune
mais peut-être que au lieu d'être
exactement deux tiers-un tiers ce sera
un petit peu plus que deux tiers ont un
petit peu moins que deux tiers et donc à
la génération suivante ça va évoluer
petit à petit sous l'effet du hasard
mais avec ce renforcement qui existe
quand même et donc on peut se demander
est ce qu'il ya une couleur qui va
disparaître à un moment donné est ce que
les verts tous les jaunes vont gagner ou
est-ce qu'on va avoir un équilibre qui
va se créer on aura toujours à la fois
des jaunes est à la fois des vertes donc
donc voilà ça sur le long terme sans
forcément avoir de sélection naturelle
mais juste par le fruit du hasard
quel effet ça assure sur l'évolution de
populations animales pour ceux qui en
veulent encore plus donc on avait fait
une vidéo sur sur ma chaîne lui parler
explicitement de la thèse et puis sinon
il ya fait une vidéo sur ta sur sa
chaîne sur la puissance organisatrice du
hasard aussi qui est du coup les modèles
que tu as étudié c'était la motivation
avait vraiment des biologistes ou c'est
quand elle choisit alors non moi je
faisais vraiment que des maths et je
m'intéresse pas du tout à la biologie
voilà je sais que les biologistes
utilisent réellement des modèles du
renaudot polliat pour étudier ce genre
de choses mais moi je me suis intéressé
vraiment que au modèle mathématique et
en particulier j'ai commencé ma thèse en
m'intéressant à une conjecture qui
s'appelle la conjecture de c'est le
coeur qui parle de marche aléatoire en
force et donc là il faut imaginer
quelque chose d'un peu d'un peu
différent mais un peu sur le même
principe c'est on est sur un sur un
rondin réseau de routes donc un graphe
en maths on a des points ou des villes
qui sont reliés par des routes
et puis on se balade au hasard sur sur
ce réseau routier et puis à chaque fois
qu'on arrive à un carrefour ont choisi
une route au hasard mais on a le même
type de chose qui est un renforcement
c'est à dire que quand on passe par un
carrefour on est déjà passé on a préfère
retourner sur une route qu'on a déjà
qu'on a déjà visité
et donc la conjecture de celle que tu
dis que sous certaines conditions qui
sont totalement raisonnable qui
s'expriment mathématiquement et bien le
au bout d'un moment si on fait ça on va
finir par ne faire plus que des allers
retours sur une seule route on va on va
être valant d'être sur deux villes et
puis juste on va faire un aller-retour
entre deux villes en prenant toujours la
même route dans un sens puis dans
l'autre et il se trouve que ça c'est pas
démontrée mais c'est démontré dans
certains cas particuliers
en fait ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui c'est
que soit mais finit dans le cas de
figure où on fait des allers-retours sur
une route soit on finit à faire des
tours sur un triangle ou sur un
pentagone ou sur un hectare grogne en
tout cas sur un cycle de longues heures
impaires dire qu'on sait que ce n'est
pas possible de faire des tours sur un
carré un carré cela est possible si vous
ne peut pas rester bloqué sur un carré
et on peut rester bloquée enfin on peut
la conjecture dit que c'est pas possible
mais d'après ce qu'on sait actuellement
n'est pas encore démontré qu'on reste
pas bloqué sur un triangle ou sur un sur
un pentagone sur un cycle de longues
heures impaires et ce qui est assez
rigolo avec avec les preuves qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est que pour démontrer que
que pour démontrer sa il y avait
vraiment une preuve qui est très jolie
qui marche très bien et qui est très
très élégante et qui montre qu'on ne
peut pas avoir deux cars et qu'on ne
peut pas avoir de l'hexagone et on ne
peut pas avoir d'autre chose mais cette
preuve va bien pour une raison vraiment
très bête de parité thé konki pas qu'il
y paraît totalement dérisoires et bien
elle fonctionne pas pour les cycles un
père et quand on voit ça pour la
première fois on se dit bon allez on va
adapter un petit peu la preuve et puis
ça va finir par marcher et c'est très
étonnant c'est que vraiment il y a on
s'en rend pas compte la première fois
qu'on voit la preuve mais il ya vraiment
une
quelque chose d'assez terrible entre la
simplicité de la preuve voire pour lé
nombre pour les pour les cycles père et
le fait qu'on a on tombe sur une
difficulté technique qui a l'air
totalement insurmontable dès qu'on veut
faire un cycle un père alors que alors
que ça sert d'être à peu près la même
chose il ya aucune raison raisonnable
autre que technique
autre collectif difficultés techniques
de penser que les cycles un père ne
fonctionne pas pareil que le cycle le
père et du coup j'ai foiré encore
ouverte
oui la conjecture est encore ouverte
donc
passé à peu près les six premiers mois
de ma thèse a essayé de faire avancer ce
sujet puis et puis je me suis rendu
compte que c'était vraiment dur et que
j'avançais pas et que donc il fallait
probablement si je voulais avoir quelque
chose à dire dans ma thèse au bout de
quatre ans peut-être penser à changer de
sujet un moment et donc voir et c'est la
maman de c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est à
dire je suis passé sur sur d'autres
processus année toi donc celle des urnes
donc j'ai parlé tout à l'heure qui sont
qui sont dans le même domaine on est
toujours sûr du hasard renforcée mais
dans lequel il ya un sujet qui avait été
moins explorée déjà à l'avancé donc sur
lequel il y avait plus de de conjectures
a formulé plus de choses un peu plus
facile à faire avant de lui avant de
s'attaquer à des choses plus compliquées
et donc voilà donc la conjecture de
celle qu'elle était elle était formulée
dans les années 90 et donc à ce jour
avait toujours toujours ouverte
avis aux amateurs de proba qui veulent
fidèles se lancer sur une très jolie son
lecteur de m mais du coup je mène ça a
été une des simulations de ça parce que
oui il ya eu des simulations oui des
simulations informatiques et
concrètement la conjecture à la vraie
c'est à dire qu'on ne voit jamais la
marche se fixer sur un triangle vous
avez toujours des et les retours entre
voilà ça fait des allers retours entre
entre deux entre devine entre deux
voisins
selon lui entre deux voisins c'est à
dire que ça passe toujours par la même
route
ok avis aux amateurs si vous versez et
du coup tu suis un petit peu ce qu'ils
soient encore dans la recherche dans ce
domaine
ben de loin inférieur de temps en temps
je retourne voir un peu sur sur arte il
s'il ya des nouveaux articles je regarde
un peu mais mais mais je me suis quand
même pas mal éloigné je suis pas
vraiment au jour le jour est en fait une
ou deux fois par an comme ça pour voir
s'il ya des choses oui d'ailleurs la
dernière fois que j'ai regardé ya
quelques mois donc quand je dis qu'elle
est pas résolu peut-être elle a été
résolu küttel n'était pas résolue il ya
un an 10 du coup pourquoi tu as décidé
d'arrêter les recherches
je ne sais pas si j'ai décidé d'arrêter
les recherches j'ai décidé de me lancer
dans la ville y arriver sur ces thèmes
du film démarre
j'ai vraiment bien aimé les quatre
années de tests pendant qu'elle faisait
de la recherche et la question c'est
vraiment posé savoir si je continuais
aussi jeu
ou si j'arrêtais mais voilà l'envi de l'
envie de me lancer dans la médiation et
de montrer des maths et de partir de
montrer des maths au grand public et est
elle plus forte et puis surtout j'avais
envie d'essayer c'est à dire que je ne
savais pas si ça allait marcher
je me suis dit bon au pire j'essaie ya
un an deux ans je vais voir et puis si
ça marche pas je reviens à la recherche
après et c'est pas grave c'est à dire
que j'avais l'impression que si je me
lançais dans la recherche tout de suite
je risquais de regretter après je
risquais de me dire bon bain est ce que
maintenant je me suis lancé là dedans
c'est un peu sans retour jeu qui fait
que je peux pas je peux pas trop revenir
en arrière
j'avais un peu peur de ça donc je me
suis dit allez j'essaye puis j'étais
vraiment attiré vers ça c'est à dire que
le lait les dilemmes que j'avais
peut-être plus des dizaines d'ordre
pratique c'est comment je vais gagner ma
vie
comment est ce que je vais payer voyez
comment une régularisation parce que
c'était pas du tout évident que ça
allait marcher
d'ailleurs ça va pas marcher tout de
suite et mai mais si on enlevait tous
ces pros toutes ces problématiques
pragmatique je sentais que c'était ça
qui m'attirait et que j'avais envie de
faire donc bien donc
donc voilà je me suis dit j'y vais et si
ça ne marche pas ça marche pas mais au
moins j'aurai essayé ce sera sans regret
quoi mais dont elle fit la médiation de
toi dans ta tête
ah oui mais je continuais oui pendant en
fait pendant toutes mes études j'ai
continué de bosser un peu pour des
associations mais c'était vraiment sur
mon temps libre s'était par exemple un
mais voilà je veux continuer à
participer à des salons de jeux
mathématiques jeux d'antan faire des
ateliers dans des classes des choses
comme ça du coup une question que les
associations en france qu'il fonda
médiation mathématiques aims il y en a
alors il ya différents types
d'associations qui est qui qui font des
choses alors je ne sais pas parce que là
là si je commence à faire une liste je
vais en oublier ça va mais depuis
quelques années il ya il ya quelque
chose qui s'est créé pas mal et qui est
bien c'est qu'il ya des lieux qui existe
qui
des lieux qui se sont créées ces
recettes eu seulement des petits
événements qui sont sur un jour ou deux
où des rallyes mais il ya vraiment des
maisons des mathématiques qui se sont
créés de plus en plus en en france
historiquement il ya le palais de la
découverte est un département de
mathématiques qui est vraiment très
chouette
après il ya une maison des mathématiques
qui est vraiment qui est vraiment
superbe aussi à lyon où il expose à des
animations qui sont qui sont chouettes
il ya la maison de ferme à du côté de
beaumont de lomagne dans la maison
natale de pierre de fermat
il y a
je sais que d'oublier mais il ya des
centres de sciences alors après il ya
des centres de sciences qui parle de
mater qui font des maths mais sans sans
que ce soit spécifiquement qui parle de
maths mais dans un cadre de sciences en
général c'est pas spécifiquement matt la
dernière moi j'étais c'était un espace
type à l'espace pierre mendès-france à
poitiers je crois qu'il ya pas mal de
villes en fait kim qui maintenant ont
des petits centres de où il ya des
espaces qui parle de mathématiques et
puis après à côté de ça il ya des
associations qui vont faire des
événements particuliers par exemple il
ya le comité international des jeux
mathématiques qui fait un salon de la
culture et des jeux mathématiques tous
les ans à paris cette place saint
sulpice à ce sera fin mai donc c'est
pendant quatre jours si vous voulez voir
parler de mathématiques pendant pendant
quatre jours il ya plein de stands avec
leur de mathématiques lui dis qu'il ya à
cet endroit là il ya des choses en
général qui se monte pour pour la
semaine des maths pour pour pour la fête
de la science avec avec en association
qu'est ce qu'il ya d'autres cabaye ali
ahani maths qui fait kiffer qui fait un
certain nombre de choses qui fait qui
est qui qui fédère des clubs de maths
qui fédère qui fait qu'ils participent à
des concours comme concourra le king dit
des choses comme ça alors là c'est plus
sûr de l'informatique de le faire de la
cryptographie des choses comme ça après
il ya j'aurais jamais finaliste il ya il
ya l'association science ouverte qui
fait des choses vraiment bien là plutôt
dans le nord de paris qui grossit en
rouvrir bientôt à un centre de sciences
mathématiques de sciences en général
mais avec pas mal de mathématiques à
drancy
voilà mais après je pense que pas mal de
gens ont des choses près de chez eux
mais c'est il ya vraiment une dynamique
ces dernières années avec des gens qui
créent des mathématiques de faire des
choses des événements mathématiques un
peu locaux ici ou là et c'est vraiment
un choix très matin jean aussi qui fait
des choses les plus haut placés dans le
cadre scolaire où il ya des ateliers
scolaires qui sont organisées par des
ateliers dans le cadre scolaire mais sur
des mathématiques non scolaires voilà
qui sont organisés tout au tout au long
de l'année et ils font des fonds des
congrès voilà justement en avril mais en
ce moment c'est un peu la saison des
congrès maintenant jean vous les élèves
se regrouper et parle de l'heure de leur
projet
voilà je sais pas si j'ai oublié quelque
chose de d'important mais mais mais mais
oui il ya beaucoup de choses qui se font
et d'optimiser ses pas et je pense qu'il
y en a pas encore assez parce qu'il ya
vraiment une demande et je pense que le
marché est très loin d'être saturé il ya
beaucoup de vent beaucoup de choses qui
peuvent se faire encore mais on est deux
on est dans une dynamique où il ya où
quasiment tous les ans il ya des
nouvelles choses qui se crée qui
existent donc c'est vraiment bien c'est
lui et qu'est ce que tu penses qu'il me
manque à ces associations c'est plus de
poids du financement de la main d'oeuvre
de baffes
j'imagine un peu les deux oui c'est à
dire que
ça dépend à près de l'ambition de ce que
veulent faire ces associations mais mais
oui je pense que globalement tout tout
c'est toutes ces structures que des
associations les problèmes financiers
sont toujours un peu un peu au santé
sont tous à la recherche on trouve plein
de gens qui sont passionnés qui ont
plein d'idées qui disent ah on pourrait
faire ça on pourrait faire ça et qui
passent des temps à remplir des dossiers
pour des demandes de subventions pour
essayer de faire des financement
participatif pour essayer de faire des
choses comme ça et c'est sûr que s'il y
avait moyen d'avoir des financements
plus facilement pour la culture
mathématique
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup plus de
choses qui pourraient fleurir un péno
henri duc ou encore de financement si on
revient à toi qui as fini ta thèse s'est
passé comment cette transition vers las
vegas aux scientifiques
oui en terme de financement a que mes
voyages
bah ça s'est fait de façon un peu un peu
chaotique disons en fait j'ai quand je
me suis lancé là dedans je me suis dit
il faut que j'essaye de lancer plusieurs
projets un peu différent pour voir un
peu ce qui marche qui marche pas il ya
des choses sur lesquelles j'avais mis
pas mal d'espoir notamment jeu mais
j'avais que j'avais j'avais un petit
atelier à paris où je m'étais dit que
j'allais faire des vous allez accueillir
des jeunes pour faire justement des
ateliers mathématiques je me suis dit
tiens c'est le mercredi après midi le
samedi les jeunes qui font des activités
périscolaires
je vais leur proposer des activités
mathématiques sur différents thèmes et
j'avais lancé un peu ça et c'était un
peu là dessus ils ont le principal truc
que je mets sur et où je m'étais dis ça
j'ai essayé de me concentrer mon
attention là dessus et de faire en sorte
que ça marche et de lancer voilà et puis
parallèlement à ça j'ai eu deux trois
petites choses j'écrivais des cours de
maths un feu sur internet j'ai commencé
la chaîne à ce moment là un petit peu un
petit peu par hasard d'ailleurs jeu
j'ai commencé par faire une série sur le
théorème de pythagore et puis j'ai un
peu laissé abandonné attendant un
pendant pendant six mois j'ai pas trop
regardé ce qui se passait sur la chaîne
avant de me revenir et demande qu'il ya
des gens qui me disaient tu pourrais
faire ça et le truc surprenant c'est que
les choses sur lesquelles je mettais le
plus d'espoirs lamentablement raté c'est
à dire sur voilà ces ateliers j'ai passé
du temps à aller dans mon quartier à
paris allait distribuer des prospectus
ans les anglais il ya un atelier de
maths venait inscrivez vos enfants ont
fait des matches ludique c'est cool
j'allais bien en distribuer des petits
tracts dans les boulangeries dans les
commerces du siam qui est un petit peu
partout dans paris et je vais voilà et
puis je me rappelle avoir passé des
semaines à être à côté de mon téléphone
en dix ans mais il ya aimé mais y'a
vraiment personne qui venait c'était un
peu là maintenant je rigole mais c'était
un peu déprimant les élus bon après il
faut dire que je me prenais certainement
très mal parce que j'ai autant pour les
maths je me connais mais depuis j'ai
mesuré à quel point mon ignorance en
termes de marketing et de communication
pour être vaste et à quel point
probablement mais flyers devaient ne pas
du tout donner envie aux gens je ne sais
pas mais mais oui ça ne vous a pas du
tout marché j'ai été obligé d'arrêter
assez rapidement c'est ce qu'est ce que
tu as fait différemment maintenant avec
le cul tel recul je sais pas je ne sais
pas exactement ce que j'aurais fait
différent différemment je pense disons
que maintenant avec le recul il ya
quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus
facile c'est qu'avec la chaîne youtube
j'ai déjà une communauté il ya déjà
beaucoup d'un point de vue publicité
quand je fais quelque chose je peux
l'annoncer sur ma chaîne je peux
l'annoncer sur les réseaux sociaux et
tout de suite et des gens qui vont être
au courant j'ai l'impression qu'en
termes de communication
si j'étais dans le même état que je suis
que j'étais il ya sept ans avec juste
même mon énergie à moi tout seul et mes
jambes pour marcher et à les prévenir
les gens sans avoir déjà six années où
je me fous des gens ont commencé à me
connaître et des gens ont commencé à
suivre ce que je faisais je suis pas sûr
que je réussirai beaucoup mieux en fait
je sais pas à quel point
à quel point mais peut-être que que
juste le principe de
dire tiens je vais lancer des ateliers
mathématiques et puis les gens vont
trouver ça coulait vont venir 7 s
c'était pas il n'était pas une bonne
idée de départ parce que je pense quand
même avoir fait un peu ses preuves et
que c'est un peu normal que les parents
n'ont pas forcément envie de laisser
leurs enfants à quelque chose dont ils
savent pas exactement ce que c'est sans
connaître déjà est simple un truc
donc ouais je sais si je pense que je
ferai des choses un petit peu
différemment quand même c'est à dire que
peut-être que j'irais pas faire de la
pub de la même manière peut-être que
j'essaierai de de plus allez voir d'eau
de d'aller voir d'autres associations
d'essayer de le faire dans le cadre de
structures qui existent déjà de des gens
qui ont déjà lancé des choses à leur
dire h que vous proposer ses services
mais met me lance et moi même comme ça
pour ça dans une aventure où je dois
faire un peu tout à la fois la
préparation des ateliers la gestion
administrative la publicité et tout ça
c'était un peu j'essaie vraiment de la
gueule quoi et voilà et oui donc voilà
c'est ça qui est qui est assez étonnant
ce qui à côté de ça la chaîne youtube
sur lequel je ne me faisais pas miser
pas sur quoi j'ai fait c'est un peuple
j'ai mis quelques vidéos des buts pour
m'amuser m'a finalement outre quelques
mois consignes mais ça me manquait ce
qui se passe ici est situé le contexte
que txt s est enfoncé vers 2012 quelque
chose comme ça dans 2012 dans les
youtube n'est pas et pas du tout ce
qu'il est aujourd'hui du coup c'est pas
évident de se dire c'est l'anarchie sur
youtube ouais ouais bah oui basse à
cette époque là il y avait je sais pas
qui exactement je serai pu dire
exactement qu'il y avait sur youtube en
termes de science mais il devait y avoir
florence porcel qui étaient déjà là il
va y avoir experiment boys
le dr nordmann je pense devait être déjà
là aussi je vais connaissez ou route
dans cette chaîne non non moi je les
connaissais pas un moment j'ai découvert
a découvert un peu un peu sûr sûr sûr
sûr le temps au fur et à mesure où des
gens m'ont parlé et je me suis rendu
compte là il y en a qui font ça et puis
les années avoué des années c'est en
2013 que j'ai lancé la chaîne et là les
années 2013 2014 ça a été le moment où
justement ça a commencé à exploser où il
ya eu je crois que la même année il ya
eu une pensée il ya eu dirty biology il
ya une ôta bébé qui équivaut lancé c'est
un peu cette année là est donc
finalement ça c'est aussi ça qui fait
que ça je pense que si ça a pris c'est
aussi parce qu'on n'était pas isolé mais
que d'un seul coup il ya eu quelque
chose qui s'est apparenté à une sorte de
mouvement qui s'est créée donc il faut
que donc ça c'est supporter les
différentes chaînes se sont supportés
les unes des autres et ça crée un
mouvement qui fait que ça s'est
installée et qu'aujourd'hui ça on est on
sait où et c'est il ya une bonne
communauté de vulgarisation scientifique
et culturel sur youtube fonctionne bien
du coup en 2013 1014 des cadres pas ta
vie avec youtube les têtes étaient si
d'autres choses pour bah je fais
plusieurs choses ouais je bats déjà
quand je vois que mes ateliers chez moi
enfin les ateliers que je montais moi
même ne marchait pas j'ai commencé à
faire des choses avec d'autres
associations donc notamment gcc c'est
l'époque où il ya eu la réforme des
rythmes scolaires et où l'amérique paris
cherchait des animateurs pour pour faire
des ateliers dans les classes sur le
temps périscolaire et donc avait lancé
un grand appel pour des associations
donc ça on y avait répondu avec est
logiquement le le cicr le comité
international des jeux mathématiques
avec l'organiste de salon dont je
parlais tout à l'heure et donc pendant
trois ans j'allais faire des ateliers
dans d'antan dans des écoles de paris
voilà pour les ateliers ludiques de
mathématiques je reprends je refaisais
des détours magie de magie mathématiques
que mon prof me prenait au lycée
et voilà il faisait des constructions
géométriques en faisait de l'origami les
choses comme ça c'était des
mathématiques ludique
j'ai aussi travaillé un peu avec
l'association science ouverte où c'est
pareil alors là on allait dans les
classes mais mais sur le temps scolaire
c'est à dire c'étaient des ateliers de
recherche mais quand même en lien avec
le programme scolaire de la recherche un
peu un peu ludique et essayer de poser
aux enfants des questions un peu un peu
vague d'une certaine manière où on leur
disait voilà voilà une thématique de
recherche et dans cette thématique posez
vous vos propres questions et discuter
entre vous essayez de les essayer de
chercher donc ça c'était vraiment
c'était vraiment passionnant et j'ai
beaucoup appris là bas parce que c'est
des choses qui ont été mises en place
aux qui existait déjà depuis deux trois
ans quand je suis arrivé dans cette
association qui avait été mis en place
par par robin jamais qui est un
médiateur au palais de la découverte et
du cou du coup quand je fais les
quelques années que j'ai passées là-bas
à faire ça ça a été vraiment très
formateur aussi pour hommes parce que
j'avais jamais travaillé avec des
enfants de primaire avant j'étais plutôt
au collège lycée j'avais plutôt cette
habitude là et de découvrir aussi que
faire des choses vraiment passionnante
enfin je crois que j'en doutais pas en y
allant mais je me doutais pas quel point
on est vraiment en le faisant j'ai un
suis rendu compte à quel point c'était
enrichissant de voir comment des enfants
qui sont totalement neutre et sans aucun
a priori sur les mâts devons réfléchir à
des sujets où ils vont découvrir vont
découvrir des choses différemment et des
fois de façon assez naïf mais qui est
porteur d'un sens qui est vraiment très
intéressant et puis c'est très c'est
très exaltant de voir leur de les voir
découvrir des choses qui nous peuvent
nous paraître évidente mais qui met qui
vont qu'ils vont voir d'un point de vue
différent et de voir leurs yeux qui
s'allume en comprenant quelque chose et
nous des fois quand on a trop l'habitude
dont il ya des choses qui nous
paraissent banales et on oublie un peu
de sang émerveillé alors quand alors
qu'en fait il n'y a pas de raison il
faut je crois qu'il faut cultiver cette
capacité à s'émerveiller même sur les
choses qu'on connaît depuis longtemps et
les enfants c'est vraiment formidable
pour entretenir cette crainte pour
entretenir cet émerveillement
et oui non mais vraiment vous pas mal
appris deux choses de choses la barre et
puis voilà petit à petit pendant ces
années là il ya eu il ya eu différentes
petits projets après des conférences ici
ou là aussi j'ai commencé à faire au fur
et à mesure faire mesure des rencontres
que j'ai faites des ateliers dans un
certain dans certaines structures
j'ai fait de l'effet de quelques
quelques ateliers au palais de la
découverte âge en effet à l'explorer
dommage en effet à différents endroits
et puis et puis voilà petit à petit
c'est ces manques et puis peu à peu un
peu j'ai fini par sortir la tête de
l'eau et par me dire ah bah finalement
peut-être que je pouvoir pour voir faire
mon métier et qui a fait combien de
temps pour enlever ça
disons que j'ai ouais j'ai peut-être eu
trois ans de bottes galère et puis après
puis après il ya eu une année de
transition pendant laquelle ça allait
mieux mais où je encore totalement sa
mémé ou la dynamique était suffisamment
bonne pour me dire c'est bon je suis en
train de sortir mais oui il ya eu trois
ans où je me disais peut-être que
j'arrête le mois prochain
tous les voix qui disent quand on sait
pas trop où on va parce qu'en plus voilà
maintenant avec le recul
j'arrive à avoir une vue d'ensemble et à
oui mais j'étais en train de construire
ça mais quand on est dedans on se rend
pas compte de où ça va et on ne sait pas
si ça va marcher ou pas aussi ça si ça
va durer comme ça éternellement
c'est en s'étonnant que t as réussi à
tenir aussi longtemps j'ai envie de dire
c'est la base tu t'es pas dit je partais
pour un an de médiation oui bah oui mais
je crois que c'est aussi ça qui me
prouve que vraiment j'étais tanase qu'en
fait j'avais vraiment envie de faire ça
c'est que c'est que à chaque fois que je
me disais bon peut-être que là quand
même
à la rentrée je peux postuler pour un
poste pour faire ceci pour faire cela
voilà je me lève
allez encore un petit peu à l'esa
si dans six mois s'est passé a pas mieux
à l'échelon plus raisonnable mais encore
encore ça finit par marcher je sais pas
combien de temps j'aurais fini au bout
de combien de temps il aurait fini par
me lasser bon et dû coûter été source de
revenu c'est essentiellement ou genre
aujourd'hui une petite pièce essentielle
dans ses ateliers ou 6 1
mais alors bas au début c'était vraiment
là maintenant aujourd'hui c'est c'est le
livre le livre que le grand roman des
maths que j'ai écrit il ya deux ans et
qui a vraiment bien marché donc là ça
m'a offert un confort qui me permet
aujourd'hui de choisir un peu ce que je
fais voilà la chaîne youtube un peu
aussi du secondaire mais mais sinon oui
pendant le pendant les trois ans où
c'était où c'était difficile c'était oui
ces ateliers la dont je parlais ou gt gt
salariés de ces associations et du cou
du coup tu as fait énormément de
vulgarisation sous différents formats ce
qui est ce que tu as des formats préféré
ou un truc bas j'ai envie je crois que
je vais répondre la même chose que tout
à l'heure quand tu me demandais quel
était mon domaine des mathématiques
préféré c'est que c'est que je les adore
tous un peu différemment mais mais en
fin de compte je crois que je crois que
je crois que je les aime tous un peu
différemment et c'est un peu pour ça
aussi que j'aime ce métier c'est que
c'est que c'est que ça permet de ne
jamais faire exactement la même chose et
puis chaque jour est un peu un peu
différent et voilà entre entre les entre
l'écriture des livres qui me plaît
beaucoup c'est dire que j'adore écrire
et c'est quelque chose que j'aime
beaucoup faire je crois que wake up
quand j'ai commencé à écrire le grand
roman démâté justement vous flammarion
est venu me demander d'écrire ce genre
de livre je crois que ça a été vraiment
avec le moment je me suis dit ah c'est
vraiment là je me sens bien dans ce que
je suis en train de faire et j'ai senti
une forme d'apaisement m'arriver à ce
moment là alors qu'avant j'étais même
s'il a commencé à marcher mieux j'étais
toujours dans une sorte de course est de
recherche ou est-ce que je vais et je
crois que oui j'ai toujours vraiment
bien aimé écrire enfin quand je dis
toujours dix ans depuis depuis disons 18
18 19 ans quand j'étais petit c'était ce
fait c'était différent mais mais mais
j'ai toujours bien aimé l'écrire et
c'est je crois que c'était un peu un
fantasme que j'avais mais sans vraiment
me l'avouer jusqu'ici et donc voilà
c'est quelque chose qui me porte pas mal
d'apaisement et dans lequel je me sens
vraiment bien et puis à côté de ça la
chaîne youtube les conférences les
ateliers des choses comme ça c'est
quelque chose qui met un peu plus de dix
jours de folie dans lorsque et sam sam
ça me sert beaucoup et j'aime vraiment
sortir un peu de du cadre très solitaire
de l'écriture est même très solitaire
des vidéos youtube parce que les vidéos
quand on les fait on est quand même un
peu un peu tout seul au moment où on les
tourne même si après on va aller montrer
un retour assez immédiat
et oui ça permet enfin tous les deux les
différentes parties se nourrissent les
unes des autres parce que quand on fait
des conférences ou des ateliers on
rencontre les gens en vrai et on voit
leur réaction est donc ça permet de de
tester des choses ça permet d'improviser
sur des choses de l'ema de rebondir de
essayez de valade essayer de comprendre
de voir quand les gens puissent les yeux
qui se déroula n'ont pas bien compris
comment est ce que je vais faire pour
reformuler ça pour que nos champs passe
mieux
et donc c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment très très intéressant et puis
l'exercice de des vidéos à côté de ça il
ya au contraire c'est sait on est obligé
d'y réfléchir à l'avancé mais le dire à
quel moment ils vont comprendre pas
comprendre et puis après quand dans les
commentaires on voit qu'il ya la moitié
des commentaires sur une vidéo qui est
dit à l'ats pourquoi ne l'a pas fait ça
là pourquoi alors à ce budget raté ce
point là tout penser à l'avance mais mes
gars du côté dans n'a pas pensé et donc
c'est intéressant aussi de le faire
c'est de faire les deux à la fois c'est
le l'improvisation ou elle peut
s'adapter au fur et à mesure et puis le
fait de devoir y penser à l'avancé de
leurs mouvements pour réfléchir en amont
tous tout ça c'est assez complémentaires
et j'aime bien dosé ça dépend si des
périodes de ma vie se taire que il ya
des moments où j'ai plus envie de faire
de vidéos et moins d'autres choses et
qui est des moments où je préfère sortir
et voir du monde et faire des ateliers -
faire de vidéos et jeux
je crois que c'est vrai ça dépend de mon
dealer peut-être des saisons
actuellement j'ai vu que j'ai pas
cherché de corrélation exactement
peut-être entre le temps qu'il fait mon
envie de faire des maths d'une certaine
façon mais oui il ya des périodes
il ya des périodes dans la vie où
pendant plusieurs mois il ya des choses
où je sais qu'il faut que je fasse des
vidéos parce que des fois les gens me
disent mais ça fait longtemps ça fait
trois mois quatre mois cinq mois qu'on a
pu voir une vidéo
et puis des fois je sens ma caméra puis
je me mets devant j'essaye de faire
quelque chose et ça marche pas et je
suis pas content et je me dis non c'est
pas le moment tant pis je t'ai vu
attendre que ça revienne va attendre que
l'humeur vidéo reviennent et puis tu
veux ça doit avoir un instant sur ceux
qui ne fonctionnaient pas un programme
des projets à venir
non non non je fais je fais un peu plus
pisser c'est un peu comme ça que je suis
je que je fonctionne le mieux aussi
parce que parce que quand j'essaie de le
forcer à faire quelque chose qui est
coupable je finis par y arriver quand
même mais
mais c'est de moins c'est moins
productifs c'est en général j'en suis
moins content après et du conte est un
peu la jeunesse du du grand roman des
matches comme ça c'est fait bah en fait
ça s'est fait cc flammarion enfin c'est
un éditeur de flammarion qui s'appelle
christophe un psy qui m'a contactée à
jour et qui est qui et qui m'a dit ah
j'ai vu les vidéos sur sur youtube et
lui venait juste d'arriver à flammarion
et et justement il avait pris un peu le
le créneau de contacter des gens qui
viennent d'internet donc pas forcément
des sciences mais ça c'est quelque chose
d'ailleurs qui m'a qui m'a assez étonné
c'est qu'en fait chez flammarion il ya
un département scientifique parce qu'il
n' y pas mal de livres de science et
bien département littérature générale et
en fait lui il n'est pas dans le
département des sciences et le grand
roman démâté pas édité dans la
collection science de flammarion
parce que c'est lui cherchait plus des
gens qui n'est d'internet et pas
forcément des scientifiques avaient un
peu dans tout dans tous les domaines et
d'ailleurs j'ai vraiment j'ai vraiment
aimé ça parce que le fait qu'ils soient
pas scientifique lui même et ben ça fait
qu'il a eu un vrai apport sur l'île
parce que fois quand j'écrivais des
choses et qui me disait là je comprends
pas j'ai fait bouger de vérifier ça m'a
obligé à vraiment faire quelque chose de
très très grand public et donc voilà
donc il m'a contacté on a été voir un
jour il m'a dit qu'il était intéressé
pour éditer un me proposer de faire un
livre sur sur les maths et et
s'empressant sans savoir précisément
encore sous quelle forme on a discuté un
peu de différents types de livres qui
pouvait se faire en vulgarisation à
cette époque là et en vulgarisation mais
dans tous les domaines que ce soit
l'histoire en philo des choses comme ça
une vie est ce que quelque chose qui
naviguerait entre telle sorte de livre
il y avait il y avait le livre sapiens
qui devait qui venait de sortir à ce
moment là et qui marchait bien et donc
on a parlé un peu de ça et puis comment
est ce qu'on pouvait faire un truc un
peu dans ce style là il y avait le
on a parlé aussi du livre qui est sa
peine c'est le monde de sophie qui parle
de philosophie et mais qui lui a été un
peu plus anciens et que je connaissais
pas et donc mais dit elie un peu ça
regardez ce que ça t'inspire de faire
quelque chose qui tourne autour des
maths et puis en en discutant on est
aussi parti sur l'idée que ça peut être
quelque chose de partir sur le fil rouge
de l'histoire des mathématiques
et donc voilà donc ce jour là je rentre
chez moi je cogitais ça et puis j'ai
écrit le soir même j'ai écrit à la main
production préface qu'un des deux pages
qui précède le premier chapitre et et je
lui ai envoyé ça et il m'a dit allez on
part là dessus on continue et je suis
parti sur l'histoire d'emad vulgariser
de la préhistoire à nos jours avec au
début il y avait le nom provisoire
c'était la fabuleuse histoire des
mathématiques
et puis et puis petit à petit ça s'est
transformé en le grand roman de matt et
qui a été le titre définitif et y voilà
et c'est ça a été un peu comme je disais
tout à l'heure sur le fait de faire des
ateliers avec avec des enfants qui
finalement on apprend on apprend
beaucoup de choses aussi et on découvre
les maths de façon différente
moi je suis pas historien j'étais pas
ici pas historienne vie tout court ni
historien des sciences ou des maths et
c'est assez fascinant parce que j'ai
découvert plein de choses en écrivant ce
livre et j'ai été me plonger dans les
textes dont je voulais parler les textes
anciens j'étais dire un peu les les
oeuvres des mathématiciens gré que ce
qu'on avait des mathématiques égyptienne
des mathématiques mésopotamienne les
tablettes les traductions etc
et puis petit à petit au fil du temps
comment ça évolue comme en france mais
j'ai appris plein de choses et à chaque
fois je m'étonnais mais c'est dingue
c'est dingue que ce concept cela soit
paru comme ça c'est dingue que ce
concept a été à deux doigts d'être perdu
et puis finalement s'il ya un manuscrit
qui est passée par là qui s'est
retrouvée qui a fait le tour du monde
avant de se revenir au même endroit et
c'est finalement la garder et et voilà
il ya chaque fois j'étais dans le drame
étonnement et donc j'ai c'est quelque
chose qui était aussi très agréable
c'est que j'ai écrit le livre en étant
moi même dans l'étonnement
de ce que j'étais en train d'écrire et
c'était très chouette parce que parce
que voilà ça je pense qu'aussi que ça
permet de transmettre c'est aussi
quelque chose que j'essaie de faire dans
les vidéos c'est que j'essaye quand j'ai
un étonnement quelque chose que je vous
dis au maitien ça je viens de découvrir
ça essayez d'en parler assez rapidement
pour rester un peu dans dans
l'émerveillement du moment ehret du coup
quand tu es une vidéo faite c'est ce que
tu as dit que tu m'as il ya un peu les
deux c'est à dire qu'il ya des choses il
ya certaines choses mais en fait j'ai
l'impression que bizarrement mais vidéo
que qui marche le mieux sont celles que
j'ai le moins préparés et celles qui
sont les plus grandes années sur
lesquelles je m'émerveille juste d'un
truc que je n'ai pas eu trop le temps de
réfléchir
je suis et mais des fois il ya des
choses aussi que je mûris depuis
longtemps que je me dis ah tiens ça
c'est un sujet sur lequel j'ai
l'impression que ça a jamais été abordée
comme ça où j'ai l'impression que je
peux avoir une idée pour pour le
présenter de façon un petit peu
différente de ce qui se fait
habituellement ou voilà et donc je veux
mûri un peu et puis mon âme en cliquant
quand j'ai une structure quand je le dis
allah je vais pouvoir le traiter de
cette façon là et que je commence à
avoir une bonne idée d'ajouter je me
lance dos il ya un peu les deux il ya
des vidéos qui sont préparés de son
urine longuement fait des vidéos qui
sont très spontané et voilà mais du coup
d'envoi des matches ça se mélange un peu
parce que parce que sur le côté
étonnement historique c'est vraiment
très immédiat cc des choses que j'ai
découverte un peu au fur et à mesure où
je l'écrivais mais par contre sur sur
les explications de vulgarisation
mathématiques il ya pas mal d'idées que
que je traînais depuis un petit moment
où je le disais accent j'aimerais bien
expliquer ça comme ça j'aimerais bien
faire passer cette idée j'aimerais bien
pouvoir montrer comment commentait le
concept n'est à telle époque et puis
comment il se transmet de génération en
génération et comment ils évoluent et ça
c'est des choses que que le auquel je
réfléchissais depuis très longtemps nous
mêmes depuis peu parfois plus de 15 ans
où j'ai commencé quand j'ai commencé à
écrire des petits articles de maths sur
internet et j'ai déjà il y avait un peu
en germe certaine idée que j'ai repris
dans l'environnement des maths donc donc
voilà il y avait un peu il ya un peu ce
double visage de
deux choses qui ont mûri longuement sur
la vulgarisation mathématiques et de
choses très spontanée sur l'histoire des
sciences que j'ai découverte rapidement
les optiques qui disait que pas mal de
tes vidéos et des moitiés de tvd aux dix
ans sont vraiment les trucs que tu viens
découvrir où il ya encore la même je
vous pose la question porte sur la vidéo
sur les anglais ce que c'est le cas la
vidéo sur les angles justement ça c'est
hier que ce dont on parle et à la vidéo
sur l'exemple ça fait un petit moment
que je réfléchissais à ce sujet là parce
que c'est quelque chose qui m'est venue
justement vraiment c'est pas juste pour
raconter dans la vidéo c'est vraiment
rude avec les enfants justement demandé
dans le cadre des ateliers avec sursis
ouverte dont je parlais tout à l'heure
où réellement voilà il ya des choses qui
est qui soit apparu effectivement les
anglais les classer dans l'autre sens
enfin dans l'autre dans un sens qui ne
l'est pas moins et et c'est quelque
chose de voir la dass est assez
troublant quand on le voit la première
fois on a envie de leur dire non non non
mais non c'est pas comme ça les gens et
puis quand on y réfléchit on se dit mais
mais mais pourquoi pas après tout et
puis tu vois donc ça j'y repense et un
régulièrement et puis je m'étais fait la
réflexion dans je crois dans la journée
qu avaient suivi cet atelier où j'avais
eu cette remarque avec des enfants que
effectivement la somme des angles d'un
triangle fait 360 degrés et la somme des
gens de n'importe quel polygone en tout
cas n'ont croisé fait 360 degrés est
et c'était resté dans un coin de ma tête
et voilà puis après régulièrement il ya
eu d'autres ateliers où on a parti de
parler d'anglais vous rendez compte que
les enfants n'étaient pas spécifique à
cette classe ou à ceux qui étaient là
mais c'était quelque chose d'assez
régulier pas systématique non plus un
mais mais quand même assez assez
régulier de et puis voilà un jour je me
suis remis à immery pensée et puis et
puis j'ai commencé à faire quelques
petits calculs et alors notamment ceux
que j'ai découvert pas très longtemps
avant genre deux jours avant de faire la
vidéo c'est le fait que si on prend un
pentagone étoiles et bien ça fait 720°
donc ça fait 2 tours et ça peut
s'interpréter comme comme étant les deux
tours que fait le trait au tour de trait
et que si on veut si on prend n'importe
quel polygone étoilé qui fait un certain
nombre de tours bien sombre à une fois
le nombre de tours x 360 degrés et puis
après alors il ya eu des passages que
j'ai un peu que j'ai coupé au montage de
la vidéo après parce que parce que ça
faisait quelque chose de trop long mais
j'avais je me suis aussi rendu compte
que avec sa bien on pouvait aussi par
exemple calculer la somme des angles
d'un cercle en faisant une intégrale de
d'angle infinitésimaux intégrale de zéro
à 360° de dette et à est égal à 360 et
ça marchait aussi voilà si on prend si
on prend des figures qui sont pas des
cercles mais avec des dt taki qui est
qu'ils dépendent directement de la
courbure délit mais c'est dingue parce
que là pour le coup autant pour les
exemples des polygones on a une formule
qui est plus joli mais ça permet pas de
faire des choses qu'on ne pouvait pas
faire avant au temps là parler de la
somme des anglais d'un cercle
on peut vraiment pas le faire avec la
notion dans le classique on a une
réalité 2 x 180 et ça marche pas ça ne
bloque complètement
et donc voilà donc sam sam à ça m'a pas
mal ça m'a pas mal amusé de cette
tournée ça et et ça m'a aussi amusé de
voir les les commentaires qui a eu après
dessous émises en mai
mais oui mais il ya certains cas de
figure où on utilise vraiment les angles
comme ça c'est à dire que caen caen
notamment il ya des gens qui font de la
plomberie qui monteront qui m'ont dit
que je suis au coude et à 45° en
plomberie c'est un tuyau qui étaient
coupés a du coup à 135 degrés en termes
d' angles d'anglais classique quoi donc
donc en fait c'est laisser l'écart par
rapport à la ligne droite et non pas
l'ouvrir qu'il est donc voila c c'est
drôle et c'est le genre de chose que que
j'aime vraiment quoi c'est à dire quand
on se rend compte qu'il ya un point de
vue différent qui fait que qui fait que
d'un seul coup c'est comme il ya quelque
chose que j'ai découvert il ya peu n'y a
pas très longtemps c'est que under
celsius celui de auquel on a donné le
nom de nos 12 degrés les degrés celsius
et bien quand il a inventé son
thermomètre c'est le thermomètre était
inversée c'est à dire que pour lui 100°
c'était la température de l'eau gèle et
puis 0 degré c'était la température et
quand on voit ça après moody's c'est un
peu choquant dit non non non mais il l'a
pas mis dans le bon sens il ya eu on a
envie de trouver
et puis on y réfléchit et puis on se dit
mais en fait non pas de bonnes raisons d
2 les deux vont bien alors effectivement
après quand on commence à lier ça à
l'énergie du matériau ans que c'est bien
parce qu'il ya un signe plus dans la
constante une constante positive pour
convertir taux constants est négative
mais mais finalement vous pourrez faire
de la science aussi bien avec des avec
des avec des thermomètres qui calque et
qui calcule la froideur audio de la
chaleur est assez et c'est toujours
assez troublant ces moments où on allait
choisir lesquels on est tellement
habitués qu'on se dit c'est forcément
comme ça et puis on se rend compte que
c'est juste une convention passée soit
voire très très beau concert et c'est
dsk ventes physiques constamment d'une
certaine manière il sera même pas compte
qu'on a plus à utiliser
c'est un très très haut du coup je pense
qu'un les trucs qui font que les gens
adorent dans tes vidéos parce que
j'adore c'est vraiment l'émerveillement
que tu partages ont ces vidéos et
c'est tellement naturel
en fait si tu dis que tu fais ça peu de
temps après ou juste après avoir
réfléchi aux trucs toi même c'est pas ça
se comprend que qatari la community 7 7
mrd aud
qu'est ce qui est dommage dans pas mal
de de présentation classique des
mathématiques cccd schiste vont être un
enseignant ou un chercheur qui a bossé
sur le truc depuis 20 ans et qui
racontent ce qu'ils disent oui le
connaît par coeur du coup il ya six ans
c'est énorme et c'est quelque chose qui
est assez courant dans l'enseignement
des maths et qui est assez de naturel en
fait quand on est mathieu sait qu on est
toujours un peu à la recherche de la
théorie élégante de la beauté de
l'abstraction en général on commence à
comprendre les choses d'une façon et
puis après on a envie de le formaliser
et on met des symboles dessus et puis on
se dit ah mais si on le formule de façon
un peu plus abstraite s'arrête plus joli
et puis à la fin on a une théorie qui
est vraiment jolie on en est très
content et du coup on se dit c'est ça le
produit final quoi c'est ça le salut est
donc c'est comme ça qu'il faut
l'enseigner est alors qu'en fait on se
rend pas compte à quel point le
processus par lequel on est arrivé à ce
niveau d'abstraction est vraiment
essentiel pour pouvoir comprendre le le
résultat final et 7,7 jolie théorie et
c'est vrai que des fois il ya des cours
de maths ou voilà on a tendance à
présenter des choses de façon très
élégante de manière très aboutie et
c'est très satisfaisant pour pour
l'enseignant mais c'est pas forcément
toujours très adapté pour les élèves
alors ça c'est bien donc il faut qu'il
faut montrer les jolies théorie qui sont
bien finies parce que effectivement
c'est très agréable voilà mais c'est
aussi bien de montrer un peu
l'échafaudage quoi quand on fait des
matches on a envie d'enlever
l'échafaudage avait regardé comme ces
bosses maintenant ce qu'on a construit
[Musique]
mais il ya aussi quelque chose de très
de très exaltant à comprendre comment ça
a été construit de voir comment étaient
disposées l'échafaudage pour arriver à
cette forme finale et ça me semble assez
essentiel quand on quand on enseigne
quand on enseigner les maths
ouais c'est le monument vient pas de
nulle part et il a fait le contraire
quel est le plus fou que keita a pris en
excès dans son livre décrit monroe a le
truc le plus fou
oh là là je ne sais pas il ya ya ya ya
eu pas mal de il ya eu pas mal de choses
je ne sais pas si je vais réussir à
trouver comme ça quelque chose de ben en
fait un des trucs sur lesquels je me
suis beaucoup amusés en écrivant un
livre justement d'ailleurs je disais que
j'allais principalement appris des
appris de l'histoire en écrivant le
livret que j'avais pas beaucoup appris
le matin parce que c'est les matches
avaient principalement quand même
réfléchi à l'avance il ya un truc de
maths que j'ai découvert c'est c'est
vraiment le tout premier chapitre du
livre c'est quand je parle des frises et
des et des pavages et des choses comme
ça qu'on trouve sur les vases anciens et
donc le premier chapitre ça se passe au
louvre et je raconte comment je suis
allé au louvre et j'avais vraiment été
au louvre et j'ai commencé à regarder
tous les motifs géométriques qui
décorent les poteries des dents dans le
département des antiquités orientales et
puis après en passant chez les grecs
chez les égyptiens chez les étrusques
etc
et puis après dans la dans l'art arabe
où ça explose complètement et où il ya
des formes absolument incroyable et
cette petite chasse au trésor c'est à
dire que je n'avais jamais réfléchi
vraiment aux frises et et je ne savais
pas qu'il existait cette catégorie il
est vraiment découvert un peintre est
très injuste avant d'écrire le livre et
le fait d'y aller et d'aller dans le
musée de commencer cette chasse au
trésor et j'ai trouvé celle ci puis de
cocher sur un petit carnet de virages et
celle ci j'ai celle ci puis qu'à un
moment donné on sait qu'il en existe
sept théoriquement et qu'on en a six sur
le carnet qu'on cherche la 7e et c'est
je suis et puis ils se rendent compte
qu'on la trouve finalement et que dans
tout le département ce que j'ai vraiment
pas céder dans le livre je le raconte
pas ce que pour des raisons de récits
j'ai un peu con dans ces jeux
raconte ça comme si j'allais passer une
après-midi en fait j'y ai passé j'avais
passé quasiment toutes les après midis
pendant deux semaines et ouais et je ne
sais pas si j'ai gardé toutes mes notes
mais je crois que j'ai vraiment un conte
à l'unité du nombre de frises de chaque
catégorie qu'il existe dans tout le
département des antiquités orientales et
là il ya une des catégories la plus rare
où il n'existe que deux pièces dans tout
le département ou qui en tirant celle-ci
et j'ai mis longtemps à les trouver et
quand je suis tombé dessus de ses bons
et ce disant tout et c'est cette épreuve
exactions et donc ça ça fait vraiment à
quelque chose d'assez fou et puis dont
comprendre pourquoi ça marche et c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
joli et et puis imaginez
j'imagine les gens au musée du louvre
qui voit qu'ils te vois passer l'été à
10,1 regarde ces bases-là peut encore du
site mais non mais non j'ai déjà vu il
fait partie de telles catégories les
vases mais pourquoi j'aurais dû proposer
au louvre de ranger les gays les vastes
par catégories ne sont pas dérangés par
siècle alors qu'on peut les rangées par
catégories géométriques
je veux dire ces deux vases sont les
mêmes non monsieur venance evans au
terme de groupe c'est les mecs te
regarder sur les mâts l'envers ils
marchent tous les appareils et voilà et
puis après une autre pièce qui m'a
vraiment étonné c'est donc une fois
qu'on parle face dans le département des
antiquités grecques la fois cool et 7 on
les trouve très facilement
mais il ya une ou trop fort qui est qui
se trouve au département de l'antiquité
grecque où les sept frites sont réunis
sur la même pièce et que cela s'était
blessé c'est aussi satisfaisant parce
qu'en fait quand je suis passé devant
j'ai remarqué qu'ils en avaient cinq des
catégories dessus et puis après j'ai
continué à le défaire tous levés puis je
suis rentré chez moi je me suis dit ah
mais quand même
j'en ai pas trouvé une seule où il y
avait les sept dessus c'est assez
frustrant et puis j'ai regardé quand
même je viens à celle ci en avait cinq
peut-être j'ai passé et rivières
regarder et le lendemain je suis
retourné je les regardais et en fait
elle est le long d'un mur et elle est
donc on la voit que d'un côté et donc
j'ai été me glisser un peu derrière la
vitrine et j'ai pris une photo avec mon
téléphone en passant la main
derrière la vitrine pour photographier
l'arrière et j'ai vu que sur les sur sur
les deux qui manquait il y en avait une
qui se trouvait à l'arrière du vase
il m'a manqué pour une et c'était assez
agaçant et helibras il n'existe pas de
j'y suis retourné le lendemain on dit
semblait pourtant j'avais bien regardé
et je me suis dit je suis dit mais c'est
trop fort ce temps j'ai envie de
regarder même si j'ai déjà regardé et il
se trouve que sur ce vase il ya des
endroits où il ya des frises
géométriques et il ya un endroit au
milieu ou c'est juste une scène avec des
personnes âgées des choses comme ça et
sur cet endroit là on n'a pas du tout
l'impression qui a défrayé aux métriques
est en réalité dans la seine il ya un
vase dessinée il ya un vase sur le web
et sur ces bases là il ya une seule
freeze et c'était une frise de la
catégorie qui manquait et là quand j'ai
vu ça ça va se fait par amateurisme et
lycées ça c'est totalement quand je les
ai vus je me suis dit c'est la
libération et sa jeu
j'étais un peu parce que après quand
j'ai écrit le livre g t ag forcément
j'étais obligé de condenser d'écrire ça
un petit peu façon parce que je pouvais
pas je pouvais pas passer la moitié du
livre uniquement a par le passé à parler
de mes voyages au musée du louvre
mais mais mais le moment où je la vois
et un sentiment intense satisfaction km
à parcourir
j'ai eu un franc sourire sur le visage
pendant toute la journée
je presse a fait son deuil l'archéologie
par un médecin est ce que tu penses que
cate a progressé en termes de
vulgarisation et qu'est ce qu'elles sont
des erreurs que tu faisais avant de
vulgarisation si tu vas voir revenir
dans le passé quelques conseils tu
donneras je pense que oui j'ai pas
encore clairement quand je regarde les
vidéos de 2,10 à 10 à quelques années je
me rends compte à quel point oui j'ai
j'ai progressé à quel point oui il ya
des choses que je sais que je fais
beaucoup mieux maintenant qu'avant j'ai
l'impression que c'est surtout de de
l'expérience de l'aisance et deux en
fait j'essaye à chaque fois que je fais
de la vulgarisation j'essaye de ne pas
trop me mettre de règles et tout ça des
fois des fois je lis des choses en
disant qu'en fait la vulgarisation il
faut penser au public au public
il faut penser à ceux ci avaient créé
penser à définir tous les maux et en
fait j'ai l'impression que je sais que
que quand j'essaye de mettre ces
contraintes la jeu sam ça me bloque
vraiment essaie des choses auxquelles je
pense pas spécialement en fait j'essaye
juste voilà de me dire il ya un truc qui
m'a étonné je vais essayer de le faire
passer et quand des fois je me dis ah là
il ya un mot où je pense que les gens
vont pas comprendre peut-être que c'est
aussi l'expérience de faire souvent des
choses soudan des ateliers ou dans des
conférences où je vois les gens froncer
les sourcils quand ils comprennent pas
et quand je vois leur incompréhension
fait que quand je suis devant la caméra
je ne réfléchis pas à comment le comment
faire en sorte qu'ils comprennent mais
c'est plus que j'ai une petite partie de
mon cerveau qui spontanément dit là ils
sont en train de foncer les sourcils
d'attendre public imaginaire il a
enchanté les sourcils et donc j'ai une
sorte de petit public dans ma tête qui
critiquent virtuel qui me sert d' alerte
quand j'ai l'impression de dire quelque
chose que ce n'est pas compréhensible et
c'est à peu près c'est à peu près tout
et puis après oui c'est une question de
décence devant devant la caméra ou voilà
deux formulations seas est imperceptible
je ne serai pas que tu as le mans dire
j'ai l'impression que c'est quelque
chose de faire de la vulgarisation ce
même de la vulgarisation des sciences
n'est pas vraiment une science de
l'impression j'ai l'impression que c'est
vraiment un artisanat et qu'il faut il
faut y aller il faut faire plaindre il
faut en faire il faut en faire il faut
en faire et puis petit à petit le geste
safin quoi comme comme un menuisier qui
va affiner son geste et où un
dessinateur qui verrait qui va qui va
tellement dessinée que après on les voit
des signes on a l'impression que c'est
facile et que et voilà mais si on leur
demande je sais pas exactement mais si
si on leur demande qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce que vous feriez si vous deviez 7 en
arrière mais j'ai l'impression que c'est
juste il faut pratiquer il faut
pratiquer ce métier
et puis petit à petit voilà les gestes
safin et puis ça devient ça devient plus
naturel et ouais ouais je et puis par
contre il ya un truc comme ça je pense
que c'est assez naturel c'est qu'ils
voient il faut il faut il faut vraiment
aimer
mais ce qu'on raconte quoi c'est à dire
que des fois ci s'il ya des sujets que
des fois il ya des sujets porteurs de
file des gens qui me disent que tu peux
parler de ça ou est-ce que tu peux
parler de ça puis je regarde et je me
dis bon c'est cool comme sujet mais mais
je ne le sens pas quoi c'est à dire
qu'il ya des fois c'est pas c'est assez
imperceptible puis des fois ça vient
plus tard c'est qu'on va se passionner
pour un sujet auquel on côté duquel on
était passé pendant des années puis
abandonnée il ya un déclic qui va se
faire que ce sujet va dire mais pourquoi
je me suis pas rendu compte que c'était
aussi passionnant et on rentre dedans
et là c'est probablement le bon moment
pour en parler si si on a des idées de
vie les radiations sur ce fut sur ce
sujet là parler de choses qui me plaît
c'est pour devenir un bon vulgarisateur
c'est vulgariser mais voilà qui ça vient
d'un vulgariser et regarder de la
vulgarisation et regarder d'autres en
faire et on va essayer de pas avoir peur
de ça il faut il faut essayer à la fois
de trouver son propre style c'est à dire
de trouver sa propre façon d'être mais
je crois que c'est pareil c'est comme
dans tous les autres métiers c'est aussi
naturel de s'inspirer et de se dire ah
tiens j'aime bien comment il fait lui
oui j'aime bien comment elle fait elle
et j'aime j'ai envie de faire un peu
pareil et qui quitte à faire des choses
qui copie un peu au début des styles
voilà et puis puis pratiquer pratiquer
et puis au bout d'un moment le fini par
faire tel qu'on a envie de le faire et a
retrouvé sa propre soit propre propre
ton et du coup quand à danser dans la
vulgarisation tu pensais pas du tout à
l'enseignement
euh tu veux dire est ce que j'ai hésité
en soit respectée cité à faire donc non
non j'ai pas vraiment un tour en tout
cas pas et je me sentais pas d'être prof
dans un collège lycée ou quelque chose
comme ça parce que
parce que j'ai oui je pense que je me
serais senti un peu trop un peu trop
[ __ ] j'aime pas je pense que j'aurais
été le genre de profs qui fait 5 5
milles digressions par heure et qui à la
fin de l'année par des parents tdk
probabiliste et aime un peu las les
hommes seka l'infini il y aura un ordre
qui va émerger mais vous n'êtes pas chez
vous c'est ça à la fin tout va s'occuper
mais oui je pense qu'il ya qu'il ya
quelque chose qui me conquis ne
convenait pas dans cette façon de faire
donc non pas que je veux que ce soit pas
une bonne façon de faire c'est juste que
ça correspond pas à ma personnalité mais
après il ya des profs qui font ça
merveilleusement bien mais mais oui moi
je ressentais pas spécialement peut pas
se passer comme ça et mais en fait plus
j'y réfléchis plus en fait la frontière
même entre la vulgarisation et
l'enseignement me paraît pas si si
grande que ça en fait il ya une une
image que je que je prends de temps en
temps avec j'aime bien c'est c'est le
côté c'est plus sûr sur la démarche
justement de d'enseignement de maisons
classiques et puis de la vulgarisation
c'est quelque chose que les les anciens
ceux qui connaissent les internets des
débuts vont se rappeler c'est que quand
on charge et une image sur internet
autrefois quand on avait des connexions
pourri et qu'il fallait trois minutes à
l'image pour se charger et bien il y
avait deux types d'imagés avec les
images qui se chargeait ligne par ligne
et on les voyait apparaître c'est comme
ça voilà ce qu à petit on voyait le
dessin apparaître comme une barre de
progression
et puis il ya des dessins où il
apparaissait tout de suite mais de
manière totalement floue et puis plus ça
allait plus on avait des détails qui
apparaissait et en fait j'ai
l'impression que que si ce dessin
représente les connaissances et bien
l'enseignement traditionnel c'est plus
la première méthode c'est à dire qu'on
apprend de façon très précise les choses
les unes après les autres et puis la
vulgarisation c'est plutôt là l'image où
on commence par donner un tableau très
globale mais très flou et puis après si
on reste plus longtemps bien on peut
affiné un peu telle chose a filmé à
peut-être chose affidés un peu telle
chose mais finalement si on passe à
attendre leur égal devant de la
vulgarisation nous devant de
l'enseignement classique et bien on va
apprendre une quantité de choses un peu
à peu près équivalente est en fête
après je ne sais pas à quel point il
faut continuer d'appeler ça de la
vulgarisation si on commence à aller un
peu trop dans les détails c'est plus une
question de vocabulaire quand comment
est ce qu on appelle ça mais j'ai
l'impression que la vulgarisation peut
être en tout cas le un point de départ
d'une démarche comme ça d'une démarche
qui part de quelque chose de flou et qui
va affiner mais qui finalement va être
juste une pédagogie différente mais qui
va faire que si on n'est pas autant
d'heures que que que sur les que les
heures qu'on peut passer à l'école au
collège lycée à prendre des maths mais
on pourra avoir une somme de
connaissances totalement équivalente et
des connaissances en maths totalement
équivalente à la fin de cette démarche
quand même si probablement qu'à la fin
c'est c'est plus raisonnable d'appeler
ça de la vulgarisation mais voilà mais
du coup c'est parce qu'il ya eu
intéressante parce que du coup ça parce
que donc là il ya deux suppose qu'on
reste suffisamment longtemps pour que
l'image commence à faire ça mais si on
s'arrête au milieu bas enfin
vulgarisation on voit un petit peu ce
qui se passe mais si on fait ligne par
ligne
et puis que celle ci s'arrête cette aube
on voit rien fait oui oui c'est ça c'est
pour ça que le probablement que la
métaphore a ses limites mais un mais
disons que disons que moi c'est quelque
chose probablement pour laquelle quand
je disais tout à l'heure que au lycée je
suis arrivé au lycée en ne sachant pas
que vous pouvez faire des maths au delà
du bac et en sachant pas qu'il existait
des mathématiciens mais c'est
probablement un effet de ça c'est à dire
que j'avais pas l'image globale je
savais pas où on allait c'est à dire que
je savais faire des développements des
factorisation je savais appliquer le
théorème de pythagore
je savais que j'avais des petits points
très précis je savais résoudre de tels
types d'équations qui étaient au
programme jusque là
et puis mais par contre le tabac le
tableau global qui est pourquoi est-ce
que tel détail la fcc il était dans un
ensemble globalement et je l'avais très
peu ça je l'avais un petit peu parce
qu'on voit quand même deux trois choses
faut pas caricaturer dans un sens ou
dans l'autre mais
mais oui je me rendais pas du tout
contenu où ça se place est globalement
dans l'édifice des mathématiques et
william ont beaucoup d'accumulation de
détail et je pense que c'est aussi une
des raisons pour lesquelles il ya pas
mal de gens qui décroche un peu en maths
c'est que c'est un manque de vue global
alors break retrouver un peu l'équilibré
entre cette vue globale et est
probablement le besoin quand même
d'apprendre quelques trucs techniques
parce que parce que c'est bien aussi de
si on reste trop dans le global ça peut
être aussi frustrant d'une autre manière
parce que parce que parce que l'on sait
rien faire c'est si loin si on
fonctionne si on reste dans le global on
a une vision un peu raconté des
mathématiques mais mais on n'acquiert
pas de savoir faire et de capacité à
faire nous mêmes des mathématiques et
c'est aussi intéressant d'aller assez
vite là dedans mais mais oui je crois
qu'il faudrait trouver un peu un
équilibre entre les deux entre les deux
approches mais je pense notamment
fortement pourpre est passé c'est
l'impression que c'est vraiment pixel
par pixel qi moyen alors une image hein
on n'a pas forcément une vision globale
mais très bien les couleurs de chacun
des pics et ça mais oui mais moi ça
c'est invraisemblable parce qu'il ya des
choses qui est que j'ai que j'ai que
j'ai apprise en prépa et que j'ai
comprise trois ans après sortie de prépa
et je me suis dit ah mais si j'avais
compris ça à l'époque
je veux dire je n'aurais pas eu là à
prendre bêtement la formule juste
j'aurais compris de la formuler et
j'aurais joué du coup ça aurait été
beaucoup plus limpide et ce serait jauge
aurait retenu beaucoup plus facilement
mais c'est vrai qu'on va tellement à
cent à l'heure que c'est difficile
qu'est-ce que je pense que le nom de
l'enseignement des mathématiques
aujourd'hui un restent stockées ces
questions bah je pense qu'il ya un peu
tout disons que j'ai déjà probablement
jeu j'ai une vision très biaisée de
l'enseignement des mathématiques parce
que comme je vais régulièrement dans des
classes je vois des choses mais je vais
dans des classes de profs qui ont fait
l'initiative de me demande qui ont pris
l'initiative de me demander de venir
dans leur classe
donc donc souvent je rencontre des profs
moi j'aime vraiment la chance de
rencontrer des profs très cool qui
justement font des jeux avec leurs
élèves qui ont qui en kaki sont
eux-mêmes passionné de mathématiques qui
aiment ce qu'ils font qui aiment leur
discipline qui voit là après quand j'en
comprends quand je parle avec des gens
qui ont été traumatisés avec les maths
quand je vais dans des salons et que
vous pouvez avoir des salons aux
dédicaces le livret que des fois il ya
des gens qui me faisait mal qui des fois
je passe une demi heure discuter avec
quelqu'un qui sait pas possible moi moi
mon profil et sa but créer un peu une
sorte de sorte de décalage parce que je
me dis mais où ils sont ses propres
parce que moi je les croise pas vraiment
en fait
je les vois que par témoignage mais je
les croise pas vraiment mais vu le
nombre de personnes qui m'en parlent je
le sais qu'ils n'existent et oui c'est
il ya vraiment il ya vraiment un
décalage et entre oui c'est une
discipline sur lesquels il ya pas mal de
dalea selon les profs sur lesquels on
tombe si on tombe sur des gens qui sont
passionnés qui vont nous donner l'envi
et ou sur des profs qui vont être très
technique qui vont faire leur métier de
façon très mécanique et trait est un peu
en ignorant justement quand on parlait
tout à l'heure des théories qui sont
très belles et on montre la cathédrale
sans montrer l'échafaudage et tout ça
perd tout son sens et des élèves qui
perdent le sens des mathématiques c'est
assez c'est assez dramatique et j'ai il
ya quelques années je faisais aussi
régulièrement du tutorat pour des élèves
de 2
deux lycées ou même de préparer on y
venait le samedi après midi il faisait
là ils faisaient leurs devoirs maison
leur exercice ici et et pouvaient lui
demander de l'aide mais voilà et j'étais
assez assez étonné ça m'a un peu ça m'a
un peu stupéfait je vais être un peu
caricatural mais mais de voir qu'il ya
des élèves qui étaient des bons élèves
qui avaient des bonnes notes et qui
comprenait vraiment pas ce qu'ils
faisaient c'est-à-dire qu'ils
appliquaient des les rechutes à la
lettre un peu systématiquement et
comprenait pas ce qu'il faisait et à
côté de ça je rencontrais des élèves
d'anjou en discutant avec eux je me
disais misons un [ __ ] de bonnes
intuitions et comprennent ce qu'ils font
ils se posent des questions c'est à dire
que là s'il refuse de faire ça c'est
parce qu'ils ont compris que ça pouvait
leur poser un problème ils ont ils ont
besoin de le faire ils ont besoin de
voir d'où ça vient et et ils ont un
esprit mathématique et c'est vraiment
bien la façon dont il voit les choses
mais il y avait des mauvaises notes il
était persuadé d'être mauvais en maths
et ça me frustre et tellement et j'avais
envie de leur dire mais non mais non je
vous fais des mages va voir elle va lire
des livres fait des choses intéressantes
va voir d'autres choses
et alors là je caricature un peu parce
que parce que parce que là je donne deux
extrêmes mais là il ya aussi des élèves
qui sont bons et qu'ils comprennent ce
qu'ils font et puis des fois il y en a
aussi qui sait qui est qui et qui vont
des mauvaises notes parce qu'ils sont
ils sont largués et qu'il n'arrive pas à
suivre le cours et voilà et parce que
souvent les profs les laisse un peu à
l'abandon mais mais c'est d'une certaine
manière il va tous les cas de figure
sont possibles et je me dis que c'est
vraiment dommage d'avoir d'avoir des cet
enseignement qui équiperait qui est
souvent très automatique c'est stella
baruk qui utilise le mot des élèves sont
des automates avec le jeu de mots
mahatma tech ou voilà on applique un peu
de façon robotique une méthode et à la
fin on obtient un résultat mais on
comprend pas vraiment ce qu'on fait mais
même façon de façon assez assez des fois
j'avais m'amuse à faire ça m'a posé la
question à des mêmes à des adultes ou
sûr
les méthodes quand on fait des
multiplications à la main et on pose une
multiplication à la main et ont fait
fait de fait les multiplications des
chiffres un par un avec les délais le
système des décalages et à la fin on
additionne et on trouve le résultat et
je demande mais pourquoi
qu'est-ce qui ni pourquoi pourquoi est
ce que le résultat à la fin c'est celui
scellé une multiplication dire qu'est ce
que vous en savez que cette méthode là
vous avez juste appliqué un algorithme
qu'est ce que vous en savez que cette
méthode la donne bien un résultat vous
avez vérifié que ça donnait toujours une
multiplication qu'est ce que vous en
savez comment est ce que vous le
comprenez ça et et c'est intéressant
parce que à la fois c'est intéressant de
d'apprendre l'algorithme de comprendre
d'avoir une méthode pour faire pour
faire une application systématique et
puis après c'est intéressant aussi de se
dire mais pourquoi ça marche qu'est-ce
qui c'est assez magique on apprend juste
nos tables de multiplication donc de 1 à
10 et puis après avec cette méthode là
on a tout les multiplications de
n'importe quel nombre
et ça marche et on peut le faire à la
main et donc voilà s'il ya des fois sur
des choses trou sable aussi quelque
chose qui est bien c'est de demander aux
gens mais pourquoi est ce que dit cette
fois 23 est égale à 23 soit 17 pour quoi
et pourquoi est ce que si on fait 17
puis j'ai 17 23 fois c'est la même chose
que 23 + 23 17 fois c'est ça aussi c'est
des choses tout bête mais pourquoi est
on se rend compte que souvent c'est des
choses là qui sont qui sont juste
intégré par coeur et sans vraiment
comprendre à voir qu'il ya vraiment des
choses intéressantes à comprendre est
que ça vaut le coup de le creuser pour
donner du sens aux mathématiques qu'on
fait et du coup en train d'essayer de ce
qu'on valait 1 tc de dire qu'il faut
faut pas réfléchir au match de façon non
scolaires en tout cas développer une
réflexion autour des matches au
programme
ouais c'est baky sont pas au programme
ou oui alors je sais pas après dans
laquelle point est ce que est ce qu'on
renonce à vouloir à vouloir que ses
matches deviennent des maths scolaire ou
est ce que mes mais oui ça me semble
vraiment primordial que les
mathématiques et du sens et qu'on
comprenne ce qu'on fait et c'est aussi
utile d'avoir des algorithmes et 2
de faire un peu de technique mais il
faut il faut qu'il y ait un équilibre
entre les deux est en tout cas quand on
habite quand on quand on donne de la
technique et quand on apprend à résoudre
des choses il faut absolument au moins
avoir compris pourquoi on le fait dans
quel cadre général on fait ça est ce que
ça signifie ce qu'on fait et puis et
puis au mieux vraiment avoir compris
avoir compris pourquoi l'algorithme
marché et pourquoi et pourquoi est ce
que ce qu'on fait est juste et où on va
avec
avec cette méthode là et puis après oui
c'est ça qui est vraiment important en
mathématiques c'est de cesser de
comprendre parce que en fait quand on
parle des mathématiques scolaire il ya
des programmes à suivre des choses comme
ça où on se dit on pourrait apprendre il
faut apprendre çà çà çà çà mais des
mathématiques
j'ai l'impression que ça parce qu'il ya
l'école vraiment le bon les additions
les multiplications c'est quand même
bien que tout le monde connaisse mais à
partir du collège lycée j'ai
l'impression qu'on pourrait juste viré
tous les programmes et remplacés par des
choses totalement nouvelle parce que des
matériaux les mathématiques c'est
tellement vaste qu'il ya de quoi
renouveler dix fois le programme avec
des choses complètement nouvelle et
c'est pas ça qui est important ce n'est
pas le truc précis qu'on apprend mais
c'est vraiment la démarche de raisonner
de de comprendre que de s'émerveiller
sur de dire lâche est en train de
comprendre quelque chose sur le monde je
suis en train de comprendre quelque
chose de
depuis il ya eu hier est quelque chose
qui ressemble à un jeu après une fois
quand on se prend au jeu et
l'abstraction et de se dire ah mais oui
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne et du
coup maintenant je sais que je peux
passer par là et puis je sais que je
peux atteindre un tel objectif en
passant par lala lala qui que tous deux
se connectent dans d'autres dans nos
têtes
ouais mais du coup si je reviens de voix
le contenu du programme scolaire n'est
pas aussi important que le fait de
développer les maths comme étant un jeu
où oui jouer comme quand mélanie en
maintenant un jeu comme étant une
science comme étant quelque chose qui
nous permet nous permet de comprendre le
monde mais qui en même temps intéressant
en soi
après c'est comme ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure sur les différents états
d'esprit entre des probabiliste d alger
de rist etc
les enfants ils ont d état d'esprit
différent aussi et
et il ya beaucoup d'enfants si on leur
dit juste c'est un jeu et c'est un jeu
de logique un peu et on a des règles et
on essaie de comprendre sans forcément
mettre des applications concrètes
parce que des fois il ya un petit peu
aussi c est cette chose en disant ah les
enfants les enfants il faut il pour
qu'ils comprennent il faut leur enlever
l'abstraction sait il faut pas aller
trop dans l'abstrait il faut des choses
concrètes non non ça c'est ça je crois
que c'est vraiment très très fort c'est
à dire que les enfants ils sont capables
de jouer une après midi entière en
images au néant des dragons des châteaux
qui n'existent pas alors pourquoi pas
des nombres des choses les hommes les
enfants ont de l'imagination et je crois
vraiment que l'abstraction ça fait plus
peur aux adultes c'est les adultes ont
peur de l'abstraction donc il se dit six
mois en tant qu'adulte j'ai peur de
l'abstraction c'est une les pauvres
petits enfants qui sent qu'ils sont plus
jeunes que moi et c'est encore plus dur
pour eux alors qu'en fait c'est faux les
enfants ils ont un cerveau beaucoup plus
malléable et beaucoup plus adaptable que
le nôtre de nous avons un cerveau
beaucoup plus figée et si on leur dit
allez on part dans l'abstraction les
nombres c'est juste des abstractions ça
existe pas en vrai mais on va jouer avec
je les accepte le jeu et tsahal et ça
pose aucun problème
mais c'est vrai oui c'est assez c'est
assez étonnant de voir que les libertés
qu'on peut prendre
et puis voilà il ya des enfants à qui ça
va mieux marcher puis des enfants et qui
savent moins bien marché c'est rien il
ya quand même des enfants pour qu'ils
auront plus besoin du concret ça c'est
pas pareil pour tout le monde c'est
aussi pour ça que c'est que que
l'éducation et la pédagogie c'est s'est
pas laissée pas une science très fins s
il ya aussi un côté voilà artisanale il
faut pratiquer à fait adapté dû faire du
cas par cas et c'est ce que conseille
que qu'on me donne souvent massives ont
été donnés on va dire cessé de pour la
libération des mathématiques c'est de
prendre des exemples concrets ou des cas
d'application même vie réelle et je suis
pas qu'il verse un bon conseil
j'ai tendance à peu forcer un retour
d'écouté que oui bah ouais non mais
c'est vrai que c'est très moi j'ai plein
j'ai vu j'ai plein de cas de figure ont
enfin pu même des choses qu'on voit
qu'on voit très peu je sais qu'avec les
probabilités il ya une époque je sais
que je ne veux plus me semble hélas
probabilité au niveau du programme mais
il ya une époque où il y avait des
discussions en lisant les probas les
élèves comprennent pas donc il faut il
faut il faut repousser sa plus tard sur
le passé je sais plus de la première à
la terminale ou quelque chose comme ça
et alors qu'en fait non s'ils
comprennent pas c'est sais pas qui c'est
pas plus tard c'est plutôt qu'il faut
foules et faire des probants avec avec
des élèves de ce1 ce2 ça se fait ça se
fait très bien et ça marche très bien et
c'est très chouette de faire des jeux
est un jeu qui est quelques rigolos avec
des élèves de 2 c'est bon on l'aimé on
les fait jouer avec un dé chacun donc
ils sont en équipe ils sont ils sont 1
contre 1 quoi et chacun avait on lance
le dé et puis avec les deux résultats on
va faire une opération et puis selon à
certains critères y en a un qui va
gagner et par exemple on peut dire vous
faites la multiplication des 2des 2d et
puis si le résultat est père c'est toi
qui gagnes si le résultat est un père
c'est toi qui gagnes
elle aurait continué à jouer et puis au
bout de quelques parties le l'enfant qui
a eu un père qu'il commence à râler un
peu parce que parce qu'il se rend compte
qu'il a moi et puis là ça peut être le
sujet d'une réflexion va me dire mais
non mais non c'est juste que tu as eu le
moins de chances qu est ce que tu veux
tu as pas de chance n'a pas de chance
et puis quand même en réagissant et non
mais c'est pas qu'une question de chance
le jeu il est biaisé et puis voilà juste
en jouant avec dd on peut commencer à
faire apparaître des motions de
probabilités et seront en vente que
quand on multiplie de nombreux bains il
ya trois chances sur quatre pour qu'il
soit père est une chance sur quatre pour
qu'il soit en paix alors après on peut
alors la table de 3 c'est à dire que
disons toi tu gagnes aussi il ya un
multiple de 3 puis toi tu gagnes si
c'est pas un multiple de 3 1 là qui qui
qui a plus de chance dans ces cas là et
c'est subtil et c'est assez rigolo
alors après on peut prendre une table de
multiplication et puis et puis colorier
envers les multiplications qui sont
multiples de 3 et en rouge celle qu'ils
ne sont pas et voir s'il ya plus de
cadres ou une autre case verte sur le
tableau et c'est des choses qui marchent
vraiment avec des avec des avec des avec
des enfants et et voilà et des concepts
il ya aussi des choses par exemple sur
les fonctions je sais qu'il ya un moment
donné mais ça c'était vraiment un défi
que je m'étais posé parce que parce que
je parlais de fonction et j'ai vu des
discussions devant les fonctions s'est
trouvé compliqué et je me suis dit bon
ben alors en plus ce n'était pas un
atelier dans le cadre scolaire
c'était vraiment des ateliers
périscolaires que je vous avais
justement pour la mairie de paris donc
c'était en dehors du temps
d'apprentissage et je me suis dit la
prochaine fois que j'y vais je leur
propose un jeu sur les fonctions et et
le jeu c'était quelqu'un qui pense à une
règle de transformation des nombres et
puis et puis tous les autres tours lui
pose des questions et doivent essayer de
deviner quelle est sa fonction donc donc
par exemple évidement descendait si je
donne deux attaques fonction combien de
bonnes intentions
l'enfant qui avait choisi ça règle le
disait si tu me donnes 2 il te rend 4 et
si tu lui six jeunes disent qu'est ce
qu'il leur en vain ab dans ce cas là
c'est la fonction qui multiplie par deux
fois la fonction qui multiplie par deux
et ça donnait des choses très rigolo
parce qu'après il était dans une
surenchère de la fonction la plus
écoutée et ça permettait aussi d'aborder
alors je sais par exemple y avait des
enfants qui avaient imaginé la fonction
qui renverse les noms c'est à dire que
'ces données 9,0 rester 018 restait 8
donc j'ai pas 89 données 68 on le lit on
le lit en faisant une rotation de voilà
et alors ils étaient embêtés parce
qu'ils avaient imaginé ça mais mais
quand on lui demande et 42,1 20,42 ckoi
et donc du coup ça permet d'aborder
qu'est ce que c'est le domaine de
définition d'une fonction voilà qui
était dans quels cas est ce qu il peut
faire des choses ou ne peut pas faire
des choses c'était assez amusant et puis
et puis ça prend bien et ça nous a
permis de faire pas mal de choses
il ya pas mal de notions qui sont
apparus autour des fonctions tournée je
vous permets moi c'est pas poli toutes
ces idées de fonder des ateliers pour
unifier finalement les enfants à des
concepts mathématiques intéressant tu
les a listé quelque part non
il faudrait un jour des choses qui
peuvent s'essayer avec
las ce que je viens de raconter c'était
vraiment c'est à dire des ateliers que
je faisais un peu dans lé cadre
périscolaire par contre les les ateliers
dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure des
ateliers de recherche que composer avec
science ouverte que c'était dans le
cadre scolaire et c'était vraiment des
ateliers où vous partez avec un thème
sur sur le chausseur chaque trimestre
les enfants partaient en recherche là il
ya on a écrit avec avec l'équipe qui en
fait ça donc avait que romain jamais
benjamin n'guyen de science ouverte
on a écrit des fiches et elles sont sur
le site de sources ouvertes donc on peut
les télécharger on va les regarder on a
même fait des petites vidéos on a fait
des petites vidéos ont présentement
présente les hôteliers et quelques idées
générales donc ça peut être tu connais
le bide aux sciences
oui j'ai ben en fait oui j'ai regardé je
sais c'est j'avais été un moment donné
dans un mail avec david qui m'avait
parlé oui ça c'est vraiment cool aussi
mais que ces vidéos existent et j'ai pas
regardé les dernières j'avais regardé un
peu au début les premières qui expose m
haies mais je crois qu'il ya vraiment un
grand besoin de vidéo parce que ça c'est
aussi un problème c'est que c'est que
les profs les profs en primaire sont
souvent des gens qui viennent de filière
plus littéraire qui ont un peu abandonné
rapidement les sciences et il n'y a pas
beaucoup qui sont qui sont mal à l'aise
avec les maths alors avec les sciences
en général mais avec les maths c'est
vraiment très particulier et voir des
fois il y en a qui sont qui ont été
traumatisés par les maths et qui sont
angoissés à l'idée de devoir apprendre
les maths aux enfants quoi est elle est
donc forcément ça ne s'est pas des
bonnes conditions pour pour transmettre
cette passion aux enfants et je crois
que je crois que commencer par un peu
décomplexer ses profs et leur dire en
fait les maths c'est réfléchir ensemble
et collectivement et se poser des
questions ouvertes et et c'est pas parce
que vous êtes prof que vous devez avoir
réponse à tout mais on peut laisser une
question on avait fléchi ensemble et on
y réfléchit voilà et si on se plante
c'est pas grave et voilà et et c'est
surtout la démarche de recherche qui va
être importante est ce que vous allez
montrer est ce que c'est ça qui va
inspirer après après les enfants alors
évidemment il faut apprendre quelques
trucs un peu élémentaire mais ça c'est
pas souvent
c'est souvent parce qu'elle est plus
grave qu'on apprendra compte et
apprendre à faire des additions chose
comme ça c'est pas c'est pas mais après
voilà rentré dans cette démarche de
comprendre et de recherche c'est et puis
voilà pigrée voilà je pense qu'il ya
besoin de décomplexer un peu les profs
sur sur ces disciplines les remettre en
confiance et leur dire mais vous pouvez
le faire il n'y a pas de souci c'est
celle du jeu c'est juste de
l'apprentissage c'est juste de la
curiosité partager ensemble et vous même
vous pouvez vous amuser en apprenant des
maths mais c'est comme ça que vous
transmettrez cet état d'esprit aussi aux
enfants mais je pense qu'un des défauts
potentiels
ce que je pense que c'est un énorme
preuve dix mois ce qui va d'accord mais
l'on voit le aujourd'hui à beaucoup de
gens qui ont vraiment gosses par rapport
aux mathématiques et c'est très
difficile aux deux entraîneurs materi
ticket l'attitude de beaucoup de mater
ou de mathématiciens mondial il ya un
petit peu des blagues un petit peu le
mathématicien qui peuvent donner
l'impression à ceux qui sont pas dans le
milieu que c'est un petit peu un milieu
fermé et puis je pense à ce qui est un
peu plus politique c'est être l'attitude
souvent des mathématiciens qui sont
assez cassants ou ac moi je les appelle
bourbaki peu trop rigolo sur les
mathématiques et un peu trop au rythme
où il ya vrai ou pas vrai j'essaie de de
combattre un peu ça sur twitter colle
avec ce rôle avec c'est pas grave si on
fait des erreurs mais c'est ça oui puis
le côté de toute façon à la rigueur
absolue n'existe presque pas enfin je
sais pas exactement à quel point on peut
parler de rigueur absolue mais on a un
curseur de rigueur qu'on peut déplacer
en plus ou moins même
si on veut être rigoureux de manière
absolue je sais même pas encore si c'est
si on peut vraiment dire ça mais il
faudrait écrire tous tous les articles
mathématiques uniquement avec des
symboles mathématiques or actuellement
si on est des arts médiatiques il ya
beaucoup d' un raisonnement qui sont
faits en mots en langue anglaise et
voile et si on décortique si on
décortique les programmes de les
programmes de pro de deux collèges de
lycées et qu'on regarde les
démonstrations qu'on fait aux enfants
ben on pourrait s'amuser je m'étais
amusé à ça une fois on pourrait s'amuser
à chercher toutes les failles logique et
toutes les choses qu'on pas été démontré
si vraiment on veut être rigoureux par
exemple le terroriste à bord vont le
démontre avec un puzzle ou genre on
déplace des pièces on se rend compte
qu'avec les deux carrés ont fait le
grand carré pas mais du coup mais est-ce
que vous avez justifié aux enfants que
déplacer une forme là les concerts
volèrent donc c'est pas rigoureux et on
peut toujours aller chercher plus loin
elle essayait de voilà deux de se dire
de se dire ah là il ya une petite bête
mais ce qui est important c'est aussi de
comprendre quoi c'est de se dire là on a
on a atteint on a atteint un niveau de
rigueur qui est suffisant pour nous à ce
moment là et jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un
vienne avec un tronc contre exemple qui
va nous dire ah regardez là ça marche
pas alors contre-exemple arrivera on se
dira bon soit on note théorème et fo
dans ce cas là on y renonce
soit on va commencer à rajouter des
hypothèses un intérêt mais voilà on sait
que c'est que des fois faire des puzzles
ça marche pas toujours quand on commence
à avoir de l'axiome du choix face comme
ça on peut faire des puzzles ou les
pièces n'ont pas la même
on pas la même mesure selon comme un
accent disposer mais mais mais ça c'est
totalement raisonnable de considérer que
c'est vrai que que les puzzles garde la
même surface selon l'arrêt la
disposition des pièces dont on fait de
la géométrie classique et donc donc
voilà même si c'est pas rigoureux on se
dit que là on a compris quelque chose
voilà mais oui oui puisque et voilà ce
qui est important c'est aussi de m c'est
aussi comprendre ce à dire qu'il ya à la
fois la démarche mathématiques de
de faire une démonstration rigoureuse à
tenir à un raisonnement et ce
raisonnement il se situe suffit à lui
même et donc le raisonnement prouve que
le résultat qui à la fin est vrai et ça
c'est très satisfaisant mais il ya aussi
le côté un moment donné de réussir à
mettre son état d'esprit face à une
forme d'évidence à dire qu'il ya un
théorème pour ne comprend pas qui on y
réfléchit on y réfléchit la preuve peut
aider et puis après y avoir bien
réfléchi et bien on n'a même plus besoin
de la preuve c'est à dire que ça nous
paraît évident derrière le juste c'est
pas quelque chose d'exprim abl dire
qu'après si on veut l'exprimer forcément
on va se remettre à faire d'une certaine
manière une preuve à réordonner nos
idées mais une sorte d'état fassent face
à une vérité mathématique on se dit ça
me va moi je comprends et ça c'est aussi
très agréable et c'est aussi ça qu'il
faut qu'il faut cultiver et qu'il faut
essayer d'atteindre ce niveau là même si
après effectivement là la preuve est
nécessaire moi je me rappelle que j
avais pas mal pensé justement quand
j'étais au lycée parce que c'était une
des différences majeures qui me semblait
exister entre le théorème de thalès et
oem de pythagore le théorème de thalès
quand je l' ai compris il m'a tout de
suite paru évident c'était juste une
histoire de dôme au t6 de figure
similaire c'est à dire qu'on a deux
triangles et y en a un qui est qui et
qui est incertain dans un certain
rapport de l'autre et donc finalement
les égalités de rapports sont logiques
et donc je regarde une figure je regarde
la figure classique du théorème de
thalès et je me dis oui c'est évident et
je n'ai pas besoin de me figurer une
démonstration dans ma tête pour me dire
que c'est évident le théorème de
pythagore à l'heure actuelle je n'ai pas
encore cet état d'évidence vis-à-vis de
lui je dès que j'y réfléchis j'ai besoin
de commencer à formuler une forme de
démonstration dans ma tête pour réussir
à me lire et donc dans ce cas là dedans
c'est aussi ça qui fait que c'était me
paraît vraiment fascinant parce qu'il
est à la fois élémentaire et est à la
fois c'est à la fois on a l'impression
de vraiment quelque chose de magique
c'est à dire quand je dis mais mais
quelle chance qu'il soit en fait j'ai
presque envie de dire c'est un théorème
qui aurait mérité d'être plus difficile
que ça a démontré parce que c'est comme
le fait qu'on le voit aux primés avec
des démonstrations élémentaire et bien
ça le salut rend pas forcément toujours
honneur parce qu'on se dit
on se dit bon c'est un théorème
élémentaires qui rentrent dans la
catégorie de toutes les choses un peu un
peu évidente on peut voir à ce niveau là
et j'ai l'impression que le théorème de
pythagore c'est vraiment quelque chose
de vraiment vraiment très profond à
mater
je suis toujours pas fait en fait
l'impression qu'il ya vraiment quelque
chose de fondamental
derrière ça qui est qui me paraît
toujours très mystérieux de pythagore
faut pour moi avoir au lycée pour
comprendre vous fera danser ni beaucoup
plus tard mais parce que j'ai déjà fait
une présentation une fois où je parlais
ce sens du théorème de pythagore et et
tend à ce que je comprenais le terme de
pythagore lorsque la vie c'est que alors
clairement la démonstration d'euclide n
est absolument pas instantanée et je la
comprends mais je comprends chacune des
étapes mais c'est pas du tout média
après il ya l'histoire des des figures
que tu déplaces et ça pour que ces
instantanés danser de joie et de trucs
bon après faut justifier de 37 et tout
ça mais cette image c'est ce qui me fait
c'est ce qui m'a fait dire de la
conférence que le théorème de pythagore
je prends un peu pas complètement perdu
que et après j'ai réfléchi du couac s
comment est-ce que je comprenais
vraiment le terme de pythagore et au
final la façon dont je comprends
vraiment c'est dans un espace vectoriel
avec un produit scalaires c'est me
définis positif si si poésie scolaire
entre élèves est égal à zéro alors eu
plus v le tout au carré est égale qui a
rien à déclarer et ça ça me paraissait
instinctif que ouais
oui mais là d'une certaine manière quand
on dit ça c'est à dire que quand on dit
ça d'une certaine heure on définit la
perpendiculaire it et en fonction du
théorème de pythagore c'est à dire qu'on
dit appelons triangle rectangle à
triangle qui vérifie le théorème de
pythagore donc d'une certaine manière
c'est comme si on posait le théorème de
pythagore comme étant un axe home et ça
a quelque chose de
deux qui me paraît pas totalement
satisfaisant non parce que parce que
concrètement voilà dans notre monde
physique
qu'est ce qu'ils font c'est aussi le
rapport entre les mathématiques aliments
de physique c'est dans notre monde
physique pourquoi je vais théorème de
pythagore est vrai en tout cas pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils l'aient localement parce
que ce qu'il ait jamais j'ai globalement
oui c'est ca c'est assez curieux parce
que parce qu'en plus voilà c'est un
théorème qui est tellement de
déclinaisons et cas tellement
d'applications dans plein de domaines
des maths derrière après voilà quand on
fait de la statistique et qu'on calcule
des moindres carrés ou des choses comme
ça d'une certaine manière on fait
tellement fait du théorème de pythagore
canton quand on quand on calcule quand
on fait des suites de quand on calcule
des variances en prob à ont fait en fait
du théorème de pythagore dans des
espaces à la presse mais en fait du
théorème de pythagore et qu'est ce qui
fait que qu'est ce qui fait que l'écart
type et est un outil plus naturel que
l'écart moyen donc c'était quand on
prend le car est la racine du carré des
différences c'est plus et mieux que
juste on a valeur absolue des
différences c'est beau mathématiquement
ça marche bien mais pourquoi qu'est ce
qui fait qu est ce qui fait qu à la fois
c'est beau matériellement et à la fois
que c'est comme ça que ça se passe
localement dans le monde réel
ouais je loupe ma réponse aujourd'hui ça
serait un truc du genre offertes les
formes gainers ça marche bien
oui c'est ça marche et que les chose de
cet ordre mais c'est toujours ça c'est
là que ça marche bien ça marche et c'est
joli c'est que c'est ce que c'est beau
regarder c'est comme ça que c'est comme
ça que les théories son élégance et
c'est satisfaisant
j'ai briques mansat se combinent souvent
bien peu macho mais ouais c'est si je
croise au fond le duel de pythagore je
reviens à cette conclusion sinon ouais
c'est par contre c'est super difficile à
expliquer plus en détail
quelqu'un qui connaît pas
oui en effet peut-être que le terme de
pythagore nécessiterait bac + 2 ou wii
wheel ou plus peut-être qu'un jour on en
aura quelque chose de totalement
satisfaisant sur le terme je ne sais pas
si ça peut encore avancer ou s'il faut
juste et du coup est ce que tu penses
que c'est important de développer les
mathématiques ou d'enseigner plus de
mathématiques à plus de jambes dans
société
euh bah oui en fait ça dépend ça dépend
ce qu'on appelle enseigner enseigner les
mathématiques à plus de gens il est en
fait je crois que je crois que
naturellement il ya une curiosité pour
les mathématiques qui existe et c'est
cette curiosité qu'il faut développer
après je crois que l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles je suis bien dans le
rôle de vulgarisateur plutôt que celui
de prof c'est que quand on est prof les
élèves n'ont pas le choix d'être là et
que j'ai un peu de mal avec le côté le
côté obligations et avec le côté j'ai
l'impression que quand on quand on a
confiance dans sa discipline
on doit avoir conscience de confiance
dans le fait que les gens vont s'y
intéresser de toute façon et qu'on n'a
pas besoin de laisser revenir et et j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu à l'école
il ya un peu le côté les ans il ya des
enfants qui n'ont pas forcément fin de
quelque chose mais on les force à manger
quand même ça alors que des fois juste
le moment n'est pas venu et c'est pas
grave et des fois des gens qui n'aiment
pas les maths et qui vise non j'ai
vraiment pas envie de faire dès
maintenant c'est pas grave j'ai pas
envie de forcer qui que ce soit à voile
à voir rentrer dans les mathématiques à
dire il faut absolument faire des maths
ou mais j'aime bien l'idée qu'il existe
une offre et que et que les gens sachent
que pas loin de chez eux que quelque
part sur internet il existe un endroit
où si jamais un jour ils leur passe par
l'esprit de venir faire des maths
eh bien ils peuvent passer par là et
puis et puis pourquoi pas juste être
être à côté de quoi c'est à dire que
dd voilà c'est comme quand on fait des
j'aime bien l'idée dé foi de juste quand
je faisais des ateliers gt1 avec les
enfants des foyers les enfants qui sont
un peu réfractaires qui sont un peu que
qui aime pas trop on essaye de
communiquer avec eux on essaie de leur
parler alors qu'est ce que tu as compris
et tout ça et puis ils répondent pas ils
vous disent qu'ils aiment pas des fois
la méthode la plus simple c'est juste
d'arrêter de leur parler de s'asseoir à
côté d'eux est de faire quelque chose
qui nous plaît nous faire que comme
c'était des ateliers il y avait beaucoup
de manipulations on avait des pièces
géométriques et des choses comme ça on
les prend on se met à faire un joli
pavage et puis un moment donné on les
voit qui commence à regarder un peu sur
le côté puis juste dans leur parler et
puis et puis voilà que nous arrive et et
c'est un peu l'idée que je me fais voilà
c'est ça veut dire que ça veut dire que
je suis j'ai j'ai confiance dans les
mathématiques et j'ai confiance dans
leur capacité à fasciner a émerveillé
pensé qu' il n'y a pas besoin de forcer
et il n'ya pas besoin d'être d'être dans
une démarche de allez allez on vous
allez aimer les maths on vous vous
assurez de vouloir en faire trop et de
vouloir à doit à tout prix rentrer dans
un système de 2 mais si mais si regardez
je vais vous faire des maths qui vont
être qu'ils vont être intéressantes qui
vont être ludique même même ludique
c'est à dire c'est que c'est cool de
faire des maths ludique mais il me
semble qu'il ya une limite
le au moment où des fois on se dit quand
il ya quelqu'un qui aime pas les maths
on leur dit mais si regardez c'est
ludique
si je regarde et je vais vous montrer un
jeu regardez regardez voilà un jeu vous
allez aimer annonce il va prendre il n'a
pas envie laissez le tranquille
et voilà donc donc c'est plus simple
cette démarche là que que je préfère et
voilà qui me semble qui me semble plus
constructive et qui me semble une team
semble efficace devrait surtout aussi
sur le sommet sur le long terme parce
que parce que je t'ai que petit à petit
voilà seul s'il n'y a pas d'obligation
c'est les gens finissent par s'y
intéresser le québec et j'ai une
question sur des en fait j'étais
interviewé récemment par
ap sol de sur youtube donc la vidéo est
pas encore sortie elle sortira dans deux
mois après
du coup dans cette vidéo dont cap sole
m'a demandé si ce que je pense et
d'enseignement des mathématiques et j'ai
eu une réponse je pense que je vais
m'attirer des ennuis avec la réponse du
dr ross mais en gros j'ai l'impression
qu'il le l'enseignement des
mathématiques et globalement des fastes
serre que poids plupart des gens en fait
si il en tire tout ce qu'ils on tire
c'est un dégoût des maths que du coup le
nom aura peut-être mieux valu ne pas
enseigner les maths alors que mon avis
là dessus en fait je vois je vois
clairement ce que tu veux dire parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens pour lesquels
l'enseignement était juste un
traumatisme est pas que un traumatisme
dans le sens bon ils sont dégoûtés des
maths et puis ça continue après c'est à
dire que c'est une matière qui est
tellement valorisé au niveau scolaire
que qu'il ya des gens qui perdent
confiance en eux et ça influe aussi dans
le reste de leur vie à côté c'est à dire
des gens qui n'a manqué qui se mettent à
se sentir nul qui se met à croire qu'ils
sont pas intelligents qui veut qu'ils
peuvent pas faire deux choses de qualité
ou que vous voilà dire que c'est
tellement valorisé que que sas appelons
tout tout tout la personnalité toute la
vie autour de certaines personnes le
fait de ne pas réussir à s'accrocher
ahmad de pas réussir à enfin c'est pas
que que ceux qui ne réussissent pas
justement ça et c'est aussi le système
qui leur donne cette impression donc
donc oui actuellement tels que c'est
fait il ya beaucoup de gens pour qui
pour qui l'enseignement des maths a été
néfaste
et puis oui elle néfaste dans le sens où
aujourd'hui quand on quand nous les
vulgarisateurs on les récupère c'est
plus difficile que s'il avait rien après
que des gens qui sont totalement neutre
sur les mathématiques
je n'ai jamais vu c'est plus c'est
l'histoire de l'escroc chez que
quelqu'un qui a des grosses a priori sur
cette discipline et qui avec 1
alors après est ce que est ce que ton
discours c'est actuellement c'est
néfaste il ya moyen de il ya moyen de le
rendre pas néfaste ou est ce que c'est
de toute façon les mathématiques c'est
pas fait pour être enseignée à l'école
il faut la prendre différemment d'une
manière je pense qu'il reste des trucs
en maths qui sont l'enseignement ça va à
peu près veut dire notamment l'addition
multiplication et de base mais toute
évidence il à la règle de
proportionnalité la règle de trois kiki
déjà fait peur ouais on pourra se dire
le bagage minimal est ce que ce sont des
réflexions autour du mot bagage minimal
que quelqu'un devrait avoir en
mathématiques
après avoir passé le bac comme ça que ça
et puis je pense qu'ils sont cons pose
la question à des mathématiciens ou des
gens qui sont plus dans la recherche en
matière
je préfère parler de fonction comme ça
alors que moi j'ai envie de carbone ça
serait bien directionnelle la règle de
trois puis bon tu même si la connaissent
pas ce qui compte finalement
heureusement le cas en pratique
est ce que c'est si grave que ça moi je
crois pas je crois qu'effectivement
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
sur le côté on pourrait remplacer
totalement programme par autre chose
c'est pas ça qui est important
je crois qu'effectivement les
connaissances en mathématiques qui sont
absolument nécessaires
c'est vraiment très basique c'est voilà
c'est l'addition multiplication quelques
règles de raisonnement quelques voiles à
m'aimer mais c'est à peu près tout et à
côté
ben ouais je pense que que si les
mathématiques était probablement un peu
plus
disons à la carte c'est à dire quand je
disais tout à l'heure le mieux c'est pas
forcer les gens mais juste d'être là et
de ce qu'ils sachent qu'il ya une offre
en mathématiques de rien probablement
qu'il ya beaucoup de il ya beaucoup de
jeunes qui s'en sortirait mieux parce
que ce serait un choix personnel parce
que ce serait pas dévaloriser parce que
ce serait pas parce que voilà il ya le
côté les mathématiques en a même il ya
tout le système qu'il ya autour avec
système de notation qui est très violent
qui est très très très démoralisant
aussi très humiliant mais mais où il y
avoir quelque chose qui serait une offre
des mathématiques en lisant on peut
aller suivre des cours de maths on peut
aller et puis c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait ne pas se restreindre à l'école
mais être la même chose pour tous pour
tout le monde pour les adultes
d'ailleurs je pense que ce continuer à
suivre des cours de maths je pense que
là les personnes pour lesquelles c'est
le plus utile pour laquelle c'est le
plus indispensable qu'il continue à
suivre des cours de maths c'est
l'épreuve de maths
les profs de maths continue à prendre
sans cesse des choses nouvelles dans
cette discipline parce que parce que
c'est sinon c'est là qu'on se scléroser
que et qu'on a fini par se par
s'enfermer sur un sur un mode de
fonctionnement
il part nous ennuyait nous-mêmes et
quand on se sent à l'aise dans une
discipline on est pas on n'est pas on
peut pas faire aimer ça aux autres et
même et oui sur le côté les fastes des
mathématiques alors après il faut il
faut aussi il faut quelque chose qui est
très qui s'adapte beaucoup parce que
parce qu'effectivement il ya des enfants
qui est qu'ils ont un appétit de science
et de comprendre les choses comme ça qui
est insatiable et c'est naturel
d'ailleurs je pense que la plupart des
enfants sont comme ça après il y en a
qui réfléchissent différemment qui vont
avoir cet appétit qui va diriger dans
différentes directions mais mais mais il
faut à la fois être capable de nourrir
ceux qui ont besoin et ce qu'ils
demandent
et puis en même temps lâcher la grappe à
ce que ceux qui n'ont pas envie
maintenant parce que ça peut venir
n'importe quel autre moment et puis j'ai
puis
faut faire confiance à faut faire
confiance aux enfants qui sont tellement
curieux quand tellement envie
d'apprendre des choses et on leur tue
plus l'envi qu'autre chose en roulant
mais c'est très très démoralisant et
puis et puis surtout il ya le côté où on
apprend aux enfants on a le plus aimé un
peu plus le plus faire les choses par
plaisir mais pour avoir l'approbation de
l'adulte quoi c'est à dire que ça c'est
quelque chose qui me frappait aussi dans
les ateliers que je faisais des fois il
ya des enfants qui faisaient des choses
qui étaient très intéressantes et qui
avait compris quelque chose et qui une
fois qu'ils avaient compris il avait à
tout prix besoin qu'on leur dise c'est
bien c'est bien c'est bien et il avait
l'impression qu'ils n'étaient pas
contentes de même temps qu'il n'avait
pas eu une sorte d'approbation alors que
alors que quand on n'a plus pris quelque
chose normalement on doit pouvoir être
satisfait et je crois que c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut développer aussi la
capacité à ceux à se satisfaire de soi
même mais mais oui je crois que
globalement il ya dès qu'on essaye de de
forcer les choses ça ne marche pas bien
quoi c'est comme les fois je lui ai je
dit c'est il ya rien de tel pour faire
échouer un enfant qu'un adulte qui s'est
mis en tête de le faire réussir c'est
absolument des décors et dès qu'on
essaye de vouloir de pouvoir forcer les
choses et de vouloir avoir des projets
pour l'enfant à sa place alors après
c'est ça aussi c'est caricatural parce
que effectivement il faut quand même il
n'existe des connaissances qui ont été
acquises par l'humanité et donc depuis
des siècles et donc il faut que l'enfant
une des propositions et des guides il
faut pas non plus lui dire bon ben tant
que tu te demande pas je fais rien il
faut lui proposer des choses il faut
comme je disais tout à l'heure juste
s'asseoir à côté d'eux et faire des
choses et puis et puis attendre qui pose
les questions qui nous demandent qu'ils
attaquaient ce que c'est et pour entamer
la première passion et puis après il
faut leur apprendre des choses il s'agit
pas de dire juste
l'enfant doit tout re découvrir par lui
même et il faut répondre et lui apprend
des choses restent passifs et non à
partir du moment où il ya une volonté
d'apprendre
il faut enfin je crois en tout cas après
je dis ça de façon là j'ai l'impression
que je vais toutes les dernières phrases
que je viens de prononcer je les ai
prononcés avec un ton très catégorique
alors qu'en fait je me suis je suis je
doute beaucoup plus que jamais des
ressources que lorsque je vais me dire
mais c'est l'impression que j'ai de
l'expérience que j'ai maintenant je
pense que c'est comme tout quand on fait
de la pédagogie il faut éviter des
grandes théories parce que des fois
c'est comme si c'était sa grande théorie
sûr il faut éviter les grandes théories
oui voilà c'est ça c'est sûr comme je
disais tout à l'heure sur la sur la
vulgarisation ou finalement je crois
qu'il faut juste pratiquer et puis voir
ce qui marche ce qui ne marche pas ces
voix là c'est pareil c'est des fois des
fois ça arrive qu'on prépare un atelier
on dit ah mais là on va faire ça sur tel
thème
et c'est tellement bien et on va passer
par là puis je vais leur expliquer ça
comme ça et et on se trouve très
intelligent d'avoir trouvé une bonne
façon de présenter tel sujet d'avoir
chopé un truc en dit à cela je suis
content de moi est petit on arrive
devant la classe et ça s'est
lamentablement
et puis il ya d'autres fois où on
improvise complètement et on a des
séances totalement géniale où ça se
répondent où il ya plein d'idées qui
fusent et où on est surpris soi même de
ce qui sort et à la fin c'est mon
ressort avec des étoiles dans les yeux
en disant mais il s'est placé plein de
trucs
les enfants ont compris plein de trucs
moi aussi j'ai compris périmétrique et
et voilà et je crois que c'est quelque
chose d'assez important aussi c'est
cette capacité à improviser à rebondir
sur les besoins sur les envies sur les
questions et à faire en fonction de ce
qui se passe et ce que dans
l'enseignement des thématiques en
particulier impression que le truc qui
va faire que l'enseignement va bien se
passer ou pas c'est vraiment la
motivation des étudiants
répète nourrie par la motivation du
professeur qui est très très bon mais en
particulier l'impression qu'en maths en
particulier où je pense que la
motivation pour explorer et se trompent
tenter des choses et se tromper vraiment
particulièrement importante et du coup
si je pense que c'est vraiment cette
motivation et qu'il faut il faut prendre
soin qu'il faut préserver tout ça est
malheureusement allé l'enseignement
obligatoire ou le fait de pas d'exiger
que des élèves qui maîtrise des
techniques ou des certaines
connaissances en particulier sont très
contents du ctif notre collectif pour
leur motivation
oui bah oui parce que ça ça déplace leur
intérêt pour les sciences dans un
intérêt pour ce pour ce cadre et dans un
an dans un système social qui est
l'école c'est aussi ses fins il ya aussi
tout un tas de raisons politiques quoi
derrière tout ça c'est que l'école ça se
place voilà dans un cadre dans un cadre
général dans une société d'un ça ça
vient de quelque part il ya toute une
histoire derrière ça il ya tout et oui
c'est sûr qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
progrès à faire pour aller vers vers
l'optimisation est ce que voilà est-ce
que est ce que l'école c'est fait pour
juste aimé apprendre des choses et puis
on apprend des trucs et on est content
et voilà sans autre arrière pensées et
voilà où est ce que dès le début on doit
penser à les enfants sont à l'école pour
s'insérer dans une société telle qu'elle
est pour pour apprendre à ne pas trop ne
pas trop parler quand il faut pas parler
à ne pas trop ça c'est quelque chose qui
m'a aussi beaucoup étonné quand main
dans les ateliers des fois c'est avec le
sait que quand on fait des ateliers de
recherche sa demande de communiquer donc
quand on explique le sujet et que les
enfants ils sont par petits lots de
table de cinq ou six pour nous vivons
alesi maintenant réfléchissez entre vous
ça fait du bruit ça fait du boucan et il
est souvent les profs sont à sa salle et
ça et ça c'est non non non il faudrait
mais même des fois on sent qu'ils ont un
peu honte c'est à dire 6 mai mais vous
mais si mes collègues de la salle d'à
côté entendre le boucan on va penser que
je tiens pas mal
à s'en va penser que je suis pas un bon
prof on va penser que c'est il ya
beaucoup de préjugés là dessus et
beaucoup de choses qui sont moi des fois
ça y est c'est des fois c'est des choses
qui me gêne même des voix quand je vais
dans la porte dans des classes ou dans
des salles ou des choses comme ça où des
fois je suis en train de parler de trucs
de maths et puis des fois il ya des
élèves qui a abandonné décroche
ils vont juste pu être en train
d'écouter pendant cinq dix minutes c'est
normal parce qu'on a tous notre rythme
on ne peut pas être tout le temps en
train de suivre et et des fois il y
avait les profs qui sont là ils sont
méchants et écouter écouter un petit peu
quand même
il est venu il s'est déplacé c'est la
moindre des choses que vous pouvez vous
avez pas honte de ne pas l'écouter mais
non mais non mais peut-être qu'elles ont
besoin de parler cinq minutes pour se
libérer l'esprit
peut-être qu'ils ont besoin de jouer un
peu de penser à autre chose peut être
discutée et c'est pas grave
et c'est pas grave et sceller d'ici les
10 km aussi à la prise de façon vivante
et de façon enfin moi quand j'étais
élève ça m'arrivait beaucoup de des fois
dans des camps tadic en rien des cours
qui dure quatre heures ou deux heures ou
non il ya des moments où pendant 10
minutes même plus demi heure je dessine
sur mon cahier et je les ai côtoyés tout
ce qui se passe dans le court chacun
chacun a ses capacités de concentration
et c'est pas pour ça que je comprends
moins bien ça ne veut pas pour ça qu'on
n'ira - voilà je sais que je sais plus
où j'en suis comment j'en suis venu là
fait partie de toute une question
c'étaient les les ce que les les
réflexes des profs
oui oui oui c'est sur ce qu'on attend
des enfants en terme de
deux disciplines et en termes de
conformité à une certaine norme sociale
qui est attendu d'eux dès l'école qui
sera attendu d'eux après l'école
mais c'est super facile mais du coup je
pense que c'est du coup un ultra
important de fabrication on suit la
logique selon lesquelles la motivation
est vraiment le truc à protéger un truc
qui semble du coup important c'est de
faire de vulgarisation de couvrir les
maths et tout ça et pour le coup c'est
un scoop c'est parfois que tu as fait
huit morts peut-être mais tu es traces
de travailler sur un livre un beau livre
je te le dis juste avant mais oui
effectivement là c'est ce qui occupe un
peu mon temps mon temps là en ce moment
jusqu'en jusqu'en juin je vais donc pas
reprendre le livre il va sortir à la fin
d'année mais mais oui là ça fait trois
ans que le grand monde et mata sortie
maintenant est donc là ça fait à peine
un nom un peu plus de six mois que je
fais sur sur le prochain donc toujours
des mathématiques peut-être ce sera un
peu moins axés uniquement mathématiques
mais un peu plus aussi lien avec les
autres sciences tout autour et voilà est
alors alors le le titre je pense que je
pense que je peux le dire même si je
pense que là maintenant depuis une
semaine il est il est vraiment définitif
jusqu'à une semaine y avait encore pas
mal de discussions mais là maintenant il
est vrai plus totalement changé ça va
s'appeler le théorème du parapluie ou
ebita à lui ses théories des groupes et
tous à la salle non ça va pas forcément
parler de théorie des groupes savent
quelque chose général là dessus et en
fait c'est le le fil rouge le thème
général c'est c'est un peux comprendre
comment s conscience souvent les
révolutions se font pas forcément en
comprenant des choses très compliquée
techniquement mais en changeant de point
de vue sur sur un sujet qu'à mon avis il
ya un problème on sait pas très bien
comment le résoudre on sait pas trop
mais très bien comment faire on ne voit
pas ça paraît difficile on se casse la
tête dessus pendant pendant des années
et puis il ya un moment donné où on se
dit mais ce problème si vous le regardez
comme ça je le regarde à l'envers ben là
d'un seul coup à ça se débloque et on
comprend et puis ça devient évident et
donc c'est un peu sur ce thème là je
vais un peu de développer sur le fait
qu'en sciences il ya plein de moments de
rupture comme ça ou où on se met dans un
mode de pensée différents et en se
mettant dans ce mode de pensée
différents bien d'un seul coup ce qui
était complexe devient évident et et
c'est comme ça qu'il ya beaucoup de
grands problèmes qui ont été résolus et
c'est comme ça que voilà qu'il ya des
choses qui avancent et c'est quelque
chose d'étonnant parce que souvent c'est
aussi un préjugé qu'on peut avoir et que
quand on discute avec le grand public
c'est quand ils se disent beaucoup de
gens se disent mais mais ce qu on
inventait des très grands scientifiques
ça doit être horriblement compliqué je
peux pas comprendre parce que s'il a
fallu que ce soit des très grands
trafics
là je veux dire si c'est newton a trouvé
un truc comme ça si einstein a trouvé un
truc comme ça si amy notaire a trouvé un
truc comme ça vu comme c'étaient des
cerveaux absolument brillant s'il a
fallu un cerveau comme ça pour
comprendre ça c'est celle ci si moi
j'étais capable de le comprendre
d'autres gens l'aurez compris avant veut
il n'aurait pas fallu attendre qu'il ya
des gens aussi brillant et en fait non
c'est faux parce que parce qu'en fait le
génie de ces gens là souvent alors il ya
aussi de la technique mais le génie de
ces gens là c'est c'est de penser à un
truc auquel personne n'avait pensé avant
et de se dire et si on regarde ça comme
ça regardez c'est d'ailleurs c'est
d'avoir une idée originale ray et puis
finalement bon après tu vois là après il
ya de la technique derrière certes mais
le principe de départ
bayer pas si difficile que j'aie
comprendre que ça à comprendre c'est
juste il fallait avoir l'idée il fallait
avoir l'aspect lisse il fallait et donc
c'est un peu c'est un peu ça l'idée
alors le le lien avec le théorème du
parapluie sais c'est que c'est que c'est
un peu ce mode de pensée c'est quand on
quand on a besoin de faire un
raisonnement quand un besoin de
comprendre quelque chose des fois et
bien il faut changer de mode de pensée
et c'est un peu la métaphore du
parapluie c'est que si on veut aller
d'un point a à un point b sous la pluie
et bien qu'est ce qu'on fait on commence
par prendre un parapluie on se met de la
tête c'est puis après on marche et une
fois qu'on a marché qu'on a réussi à
faire notre tâche sous le parapluie
c'est à dire réussir à marcher sans être
mouillé on peut enlever le parapluie en
est arrivé là voulaient s'en est mouillé
et donc le parapluie c'est un peu la
métaphore du changement de point de vue
du changement de ses traits c'est très
exaltant de canton réussi à comprendre
ça et donc on a un problème on change de
point de vue on résoudre notre problème
notre point de vue puis après on revient
à notre mode de départ et on a résolu le
problème et c'est vrai il ya plein de
vie plein de petites choses comme ça
qu'ils sont et il ya beaucoup de savants
qui se voit là qu'ils savaient qui se
distingue par cette capacité juste à
avoir des points de vue différents et je
raconte une anecdote que j'ai découverte
il n'est pas très longtemps fin il ya
quelques mois et que je vais parler un
peu au début du livre pour pour
introduire la personnalité parce que
j'ai parlé de john et père et pour
introduire un peu sa personnalité pour
pour railler pour expliquer un peu que
justement il un peu ce point de vue un
peu original qui fait qu'ils voient les
problèmes différemment ou où il avait un
voisin qui avait des pigeonniers il
avait plein de pigeons et les pigeons
venaient manger les grains dans les
champs de nevers et du coup je vais
faire une haie père avait à 10 avait dit
à son voisin mais si tu si tu retiens
pas tes plus les pigeons sur les
confisquent et le voisin il y avait
avait rayonné en lui disant mais peut
être court toujours courir pour
rattraper mes pigeons et le lendemain
matin quand il s'est levé le voisin il a
constaté que john né père était en train
d'attraper tous ces pigeons et les
mettre dans un grand sac pour les
capturer et en fait et en fait ce
qu'elle fait des pères c'est simplement
qu'ils avaient ils avaient semé des
graines dans son champ qui était imbibé
de brandy donc en fait les pigeons
étaient complètement saouls et être
ramassées il pouvait plus voler et donc
voilà c'est cette idée de rupture c'est
de se dire même si on veut attraper des
pigeons la façon spontanée de penser
c'est comment est ce que je fais pour
courir plus vite que je peux leur courir
derrière ce pc de les attraper je peux
imaginer une grande épuisette et tout ça
et ça peut paraître très compliqué et
puis d'un seul coup il ya un changement
de point de vue qui fait ben si au lieu
d'essayer d'être plus rapide que les
pigeons juste je trouver un moyen de
rendre les pigeons vont un rapide que
moi et puis voilà le problème est résolu
par une astuce toute simple donc cesser
c'est un peu de bon là c'est pas très
scientifique puis en plus c'est
probablement une légende on n'est pas
sûr que ce soit vraiment pas ce que tu
veux mais je
ce genre de petites anecdotes parce que
même si c'est des légendes ça dit
quelque chose de cet état d'esprit ou ou
en fait il faut être astucieux il faut
pas il faut pas essayer le but n'est pas
d'être le plus fort le meilleur le même
celui qui est capable de faire le plus
de choses mais il faut être astucieux et
quand on est atterré cieux on trouve le
moyen de s'en sortir par des pirouettes
et c'est souvent comme ça qu'on réussit
à changer de point de vue
du coup dans livre tu prends plusieurs
exemples j'imagine des histoires oui il
y aura pas mal de your eyes aura
normalement 5 grande partie et chaque
partie sera une sorte de mini enquête
qui a abouti à une sorte de sommet de
l'histoire des sciences vous voilà en
ayant en ayant changé de point de vue on
a réussi un on a réussi à comprendre
quelque chose de profond tu es teese est
un petit peu les cinq parties les cinq
partis alors pour donner une idée alors
la première partie ça va être sûr sur
quelque chose qui s'appelle la loi de
benford donc je vous laisse découvrir je
veux pas trop en venir à me dire ce
qu'il faut vous découvriez juste comme
ça
après on va parler de la théorie de la
gravitation de newton puisque là aussi
il ya des choses vraiment un ca c mais
en passant par des chemins un petit peu
un petit peu amusant et on va parler de
l'infini en mathématiques
on va parler de géométrie non
euclidienne et puis à la fin on parlera
un petit peu de relativité générale donc
sa relativité non pas qu'il restera
intérêt général
ça va plus le chemin parcouru
julie bresset c'est pour noël prochain
ouais c'est ça normalement ça devrait
sortir vers horta mon public c'est vers
la fin d'interview est ce que j'aimerais
quel message je t'aimerai que les
auditeurs retiennent de ce podcast
eh bien je voudrais leur dire que que
les mathématiques c'est passionnant et
que et que peut-être je sais pas je ne
vous connais pas donc je peux être que
vous aimez ça peut-être que vous aimez
mort c'est a priori si c'est des gens
qui regardent tâche mc des gens qui a
priori sont pas totalement fâché avec
les mathématiques ou en tout cas son
sont ouverts à l'idée de à l'idée de
creuser un petit peu dans ce domaine là
mais que mais qui a tellement de choses
passionnantes à découvrir là dedans que
il faut il faut rester curieux est que
et qu'on n'a jamais appris on n'a jamais
fini d'en apprendre dans cette
discipline qu'on n'a jamais fini d'être
surpris et à tous les niveaux que ce
soit sur des gestes compliqués que ce
soit sur des choses simples que ce soit
sur des choses belles exaltante
technique il ya c'est vraiment une
discipline qui est polychromie à 4 plein
de couleurs kaeppelin de tant de formes
différentes et puis chacun à chacun et
chacun peut trouver sa voix à
l'intérieur de ce monde merveilleux
c'est même déjà j'étais un juriste
peuvent trier très coulant lemaitre oui
tout le monde et est ce que tu vas finir
avec deux recommandations de vidéos
podcasts livres personnes à suivre
oui bah du coup alors qu'est ce qu'il
fait il faut que je choisis ce qu'est ce
que je vis en ce moment alors déjà je
vais commencer je peux commencer par un
parent livre s'éloigner un petit peu des
maths mais il ya un livre que je suis en
train de lire en ce moment qui
m'intéresse qui était vraiment très très
intéressant ça s'appelle le français est
à nouveau de l'aveyron et si j'allais là
ils sont deux à l'avoir écrit mais je le
connais il ay l'avion parce que je la
suis sur ce que sur twitter etc
j'espère que j'ai cachait pas son nom
que je recherche
et donc c'est sûr c'est sur la
linguistique c1 face et ça ça parle ou
oui c'est ça c'est maria callas et voilà
c'est l'essai sur ces sur l'évolution de
la sur le français et sur l'évolution
des langues et sur le fait que sur le
fait que les longues toujours évolué et
qu'il faut se l'approprier et que et
qu'on a le droit de faire des
changements et qu'il faut pas trop se
résumer rapidement mais il faut pas
crier ton pas trop écouter les académies
qui
ce que c'est comme ça qu'on parle bien
et que c'est pas autrement et défend la
liberté mathématiques et défendre un peu
plus sa liberté linguistique il faut il
faut des poux défendre la liberté un peu
un peu un peu dans tout dans tous les
domaines et alors veut un deuxième
qu'est ce que je peux qu est ce que je
peux citer en ce moment alors le
deuxième livre que je suis en train de
lire en ce moment c'est le dernier livre
de florence porcel qui est vraiment très
alors là je les plus si j'ai pu j'ai
plus le titre mais c'est les big secrets
de l'univers ou quelque chose comme ça
qui est qui et qui est assez intéressant
moi j'imagine que les gens qui te
suivent leur site à mal connaissent
florence mail à sa chaîne qui est qui et
qui est prêt quelques moi j'adore
j'adore ça ce qu'est ce qu'elle fait
j'adore la façon dont elles tentaient
d'expliquer les choses de l'univers dont
elle nous entraîne dans son monde donc
donc oui c'était pas une découverte de
treize imagine que les gens qui tiennent
certainement un peu la connaître déjà
mais je leur dis quand même parce que
j'en ai compris ce qu'elle s'y faire
merci veut que michael je pense qu'il ya
d'autres choses à rajouter je crois que
là je ne sais pas si ça va me vient de
venir maintenant qu'on a on a balayé pas
mal de sujets dont le verdict a vu
michael imappi aux éditeurs dans merci à
la ligue et à commenter tout ça et à une
prochaine fois probable une prochaine
fois